on dira je dis pas de bêtises almira
skripchenko non pas pour le moment ça va
arriver ça va ça va j'ai tenu dix
secondes sans betty je suis très bien et
coûtent amira c'est un honneur de
t'avoir en notre compagnie je suis très
heureux de commenter avec toi moi
j'attendais la compétition pour te le
dire franchement j'attendais à partir
des demi finales parce qu'avant c'était
un peu long on va se parler franchement
mais à partir des deux mis là ça devient
intéressant parce qu'ils restent les
meilleures joueuses du monde et on va
avoir un super spectacle
je comprends ag commenté le match
précédente de cathy rénale haguenau en
anglais et j'ai été confrontée pour la
première fois ce format et ça c'est pas
si évident je ne sais pas sûr que que ce
format et est très très populaire
probablement je ne sais pas j'ai bien
aimé le tournant que nous avons organisé
l'année dernière
non là c'était 7 avait bien aimé oui je
viens mais donc je me suis dit que
peut-être il est temps de changer un peu
et en plus je n'aime pas tellement le
bol est je comprends que c'est beau
c'est un exercice est extrêmement
spectaculaire mais bon on a forcément
éveillé en voir avec les échecs tels que
je le perçois c'est souvent un petit peu
frustrant parce que ce soit à un match
très serré qui se décident en bullet et
du coup tu es déçu parce que ça se finit
sur du bullet aux mondiaux à 4 attendue
chacin missclick à mon élan mais aux
mondiaux ce qui s'est dit et ça y est
j'ai raté un nouveau souffle et d'or
dans l'es4 ouais donc du coup juste
avant de se lancer dans la partie ou
alors le match et décide avant le bullet
et du coûte à l'état les 45 dernières
minutes qui sont un peu perdus quoi
c'est pour ça que c'est un peu bizarre
mais peu importe on va se lancer dans le
match et est ce que tu as une favorite
déjà toi je pense que que tu rim hadad
nom et d'une grande favorite au fait de
ce match est bon mais à part que c'est
une excellente joueuse elle a gagné le
championnat du monde de bled 6 3 fois et
c'est une joueuse absolument
exceptionnelle elle a un style ont fait
le match que je commentais c'était nana
djimou du compte retirer malades non
c'était un clash de deux styles que
thierry n'a plus avec un style classique
nana qui veut des fêtes créer un chaos
sur l'échiquier à chaque fois là je me
dis les deux styles de carita et de
l'agglo sont à peu près similaires mais
catherine main est une joueuse qui est
bien plus forte surtout en baisse
je connais assez comme quand j'ai vécu à
moscou je connais assez bien sacha donc
son son compagnon et je connais assez
bien katia aussi donc malheureusement
pour moi ce sera le choix du coeur en
plus de ça même si harry gamin je trouve
que là elle fait des très belles parties
tu vois pour avoir vu son match aussi
c'est une ruse qui agréable à suivre
ben oui tu as tout à fait raison parce
que pour avoir joué les deux joueuses je
sais à quel point c'est difficile n'est
pas seulement glissé tous les partis
classiques
j'aime beaucoup le style de haricots je
pense que dans les partis quand on a
joué ensemble le seul reproche que je
pouvais le faire pour une joueuse d'un
tel niveau c'est que toutes les
effectuer un travail psychologique
je l étais souvent d'accord pour un
match nul dans les positions supérieures
mais pas mais si on la joue elle est
capable de battre et fanny les
meilleures joueuses du monde
well as tu penses elle un petit un petit
blocage psychologique un peu pénible des
flux oui peut-être juste et je le sais
encore une fois personnellement quel
point c'est difficile d'avoir confiance
en soi donc je pense que peut-être cette
année le mans sur lequel sur lequel elle
a travaillé et ça se ressent aussi dans
cette partie mais pour moi que serena
elle est bon si je donne un petit chalet
elle est très complète elle est aussi
très forte en finale ce qui j'ai pas
envie de 10
rare mais j'ai l'impression que son
niveau en finale est plus fort que son
classement elo tu vois c'est rennes ça
fait partie encore une fois de cette l
éducation classique c'est pour moi c'est
un c'est une pièce à conviction tu vois
que terrine avec noël représentent ces
joyaux de l'école safetic quelque part
salué une érudition absolument
incroyable là elle a effectué le plan
typique pour cette supposition et l'a
transféré le cavalier un g6 pour le
moment je pense que c'est une partie
tout à fait qu il est vrai parce que les
deux les 12 à caen et effectuer les
plantes typiques pour cette position
donc les blancs ont transféré le g3
après pompe et 7 des quatre les blancs
peut-être sont en tout petit peu mieux
mais comme je ne joue pas cette position
mais tout ce qui est marrant c'est que
le bois cate finalement il a tu vois je
me poserai la question quand elle a joué
je suis si elle a fait à 6b 5 finalement
avec les noirs un plan classique mais ça
un peu justifié le coup à 4 au final oui
par rapport à la par rapport aux faits
qui revient à 4 tôt en faisant ça
quelque part tu donnes fin pas que tu
donne raison mais du coup le a4 de ton
adversaire devient complètement justifié
quoi oui non peut-être pour moi le coin
4 si on peut l'exploiter
il fallait le faire concrètement le tout
de suite elle fait le jouet des cinq
essais dans l'ouverture
donc il fait je joue cette cette
position là avec le couleurs envers soi
l'oeil ce genre des coudes 16
normalement les blanches de d4 donc si
on pouvait exploiter le couac hâte
surtout avec fougue et 4 qui peut
arriver le clouage d'encausse
après après vu toutes les bizarreries
qui a dans les ouvertures dernièrement
si ça se trouve c'est théorique j'ai
envie de te dire c'est j'ai raté encore
c'est possible que ouais
moi je connais pas honnêtement mais tu
vas vu tous les trucs qu'on voit
maintenant sagna pur plus rien ne
m'étonne en fait ya les h4 tu tu as déjà
vu ça le des quatre cavaliers m6 et 4g 6
h 4 oui mais c'est pour moi c'est tout à
fait logique encore une fois h4 après je
sais c'est un coup ce serait
probablement par l'ordinateur et
sélectivement en fait on voit à quel
point les ordinateurs ont changé à le
spectre des coups qu'on envisage tu vois
le spectre des coûts candidats à randy
moins de 3 mais maintenant fait quelque
part mais surprend le plus c'est à quel
point je traîne des coûts est élargie et
parfois ce sont les coups qu un esprit
mans ne va pas forcément un visage et
mais la a4 mais bon là on a une position
tout à fait correct en tâtant une menace
est là les deux fous braqués sur le
centre le fou à saly le futsal 6 elle
menace issia ce qu'est ce qui se passe
at en flèche 6 alors fois mais c'est un
sacré pied standard dans cette position
là et c'est un super sacrifices parce
que j'achète un match et je ne vois pas
comment on peut protéger et le math et
le cowboy un g6 j'aimerais donc le
cavalier injustice est un prisme one man
et hillion voyons maintenant ce que
valait 5 c oui c'est un super secret
chiche et un est assez typique comme
quoi une fois dans cette position en
fait j'en fais trois dames des deux avec
les deux tours a des seins mais on
regarde toujours sur quinze pièces ouais
mais là je sais pas ce que tu lis ici on
part du principe que prisent père et ça
a l'air d'être perdants et tu fais quoi
du coup pas déjà testé sur côté perdants
avec les noirs mais comment tu luttes
parce qu'il ya cavaliers f5 qui peut
arriver aux suivants ou même tu sais
[ __ ] en gc 3 prend cavaliers f5 et
d'un match si c'est ça recommence oui
oui on en a mais cette position me
semble maintenant complètement perdue je
pense que katia united a fait tu vois
c'est curieux et les parents près encore
dans le match et
car ils achètent c'est une bonne
tentative pour essayer de jouer
oui tu peux pas prendre les faux bien
évidemment mais quand il a justement dit
après qu'elle valait 5 je ne sais je ne
vois même pas ce qu'on va faire c'est un
coup tellement simple tellement humain
en cloche et puis tu peux vraiment pas
défendre g7 n'a aucune pièce pour
défendre ses pions et on voit que le fou
un ascète est complètement hors jeu
voilà c'est le vrai problème de cette
position c'est le fou en assiette sans
le cavalier associés si tu vois pour
effectuer la pression sur le plan des 4
il est complètement je suis quand même
un petit peu surpris du fou et trois
retours à sais pas ce qu'il se passe
attend peut-être qu'elle voulait prendre
1 ghz et 5 ghz arm officiel est ce qu'il
y avait quelque chose oui il y avait il
y avait peut-être oui c'est sûrement ça
l'idée oui les dettes défense s'est
passé avait dedans alors attends
l'amiable tour andy est ce qu'il n'ya
pas il devait y avoir une idée sur des
points 5 fu prend aux trois
intermédiaires contre-attaqué vadam 500
idées et scully si elle rentre dans la
finale ou quoi ça peut c'est pas gagné
gagné en réalité pour les blancs bon c
est compter un avantage énorme mais
c'est pas fini fini quoi qu'elle est née
g5 donc attention à la dame que j'ai
cinq projets cinq compères la dame donc
avec les filiales ou efsa est aussi fo 7
6 je ne suis pour rien donc le labour
c'est une position il ya trop de menace
d'un coup j'ai cinq ans le problème en
fait c'est que tu peux pas tout les dire
parce qu'il ya ya tellement de menaces
attention à dépassement d'un dame projet
3d 3 tu as ou des trois dames projet 3
wii et d'un projet 3 pour le moment et
ce n'est pas une menace
il ya peut-être des petits pièges qu'ils
sont en train de se construire la côte
est côté katia heureusement quand j'ai
changé aussi d'ordinateurs parce qu'il
ya quelques jours des les amis dans les
commentaires je voyais même pas l'échec
est sûre je dis moi ça dans deux
semaines il n'ya pas mentalement je dis
mieux nous le pus réda babouche là c'est
parfait au moins je vois là tu vois les
pièces oui je vois les pièces
en fait je vais voir si les flèches
c'est parfait c'est utile même pour les
grands maîtres la flèche donc qu'elle a
décidé de prendre à laquelle les termes
de huit bons ses positions et je pense
que tu irais ma garde quand même
quelques temps je ne sais pas je dirais
tu vois si on parle en termes
mathématiques tu as 5 10% de chance de
sauver quelque chose oui mais aux échecs
c'est rare quand on évalue la position
certes anglet se regardent à la
récupérer à 4 les revenus avec le fou
est là quoi elle un pion pour la qualité
elle est même pas tant derrière que ça
au final
katia au niveau du matériel oui mais
c'est pour ça que j'ai été surprise par
faut un fou des cinq jeux regarder si on
pouvait jouer 45 et prendra le plan des
quatre je pense que c'était une bonne
idée elle en train de revenir sur les
pions des cas justement mais elle perd
1,4 ok ça peu cavalier fait trottoirs et
damages 5 peut-être mais alors
chaussettes et sur d'un même si ça peut
être fait preuve cette quand même
dans tous les cas avec cavalli g5 gamme
comme ses trois bonnes tentatives la
queue manège 5,8
hayatou qui tombe ça c'est un vrai
massacre
cc je me suis dit je vais je devais me
retenir et ne pas donner des pronostics
d'un mètre quatre vingt sept
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe moi je crois
qu'il ya tout eu peu aussi juste faire
dame prend ses trois tours ont des
ratios pas t'embêter mais bondarev 4
beaucoup plus forts évidemment de toute
façon j'ai envie de dire face à des
joueuses de ce niveau là il vaut mieux
tuer sur le champ plutôt que de laisser
une chance en finale elle a bien fait à
arica de prendre son temps et de
réfléchir pour l'edf cardin écoute ça
fait 1-0
ça fait 1-0 et
et c'est pas la favorite qu'on a donnée
pour le moment qui mène oui ça passe
c'est l'évidence et va complètement
dérouté que tirer d'un à quatre mais oui
peut-être des cinq du coût justifié le
défaut bessac mais je me suis dis je je
n'ose pas y croire
clairement mais ce clic mais ouais c'est
ça c'est surtout que à 3,5 ou qui existe
et qui est connu c'est pour ça et ce
avec l'idée de garder le fou sur la
grande diagonale sais pas c'est pas
forcément comprendre donc le pire très
bon choix car je sais plus contre qui je
l'avais vu jouer dans j'ai déjà vu
plusieurs matches d'arica mais je les ai
vus utilisé contre une jeune ans ce
n'était pas contre marie se bat qu'elle
avait joué beaucoup de fierté qu'elle
avait vraiment réussi à dominer avec
avec les noirs et je trouvais qu'elle
ait joué très bien c'est pire que je
sais je sais plus si c'était contre
marie ce bagout une autre joueuse mais
c'est une ouverture qu'elle gère bien
mais d'ailleurs elle le joue avec les
deux couleurs et qu'est ce que je
voulais dire parce que pour la première
fois je vois qu'on a ici un chat je me
laisse aller c'est la deuxième occasion
pour moi j'espère pas la dernière
et je vois que c'est génial
katia aussi à la elle a sonné mots tu as
là sont des mots de bain elle passe
comme elle les francophones allaient
passer une fois nous un petit peu parlé
on a en parlé d échec et nous avait dit
elle nous a dit qu'elle avait lu tolstoï
à 12 ans oui c'est vrai non mais c'est
incroyable tu as une fan ou à 12 ans on
disait
lisez les malheurs de sophie si tu
connais oui je connais les malheurs de
ce fait mais pour nous c'était des
lectures aussi obligatoire dans un sens
on dit bon peut-être un peu plus tard
nous impose peut-être ont peut-être pas
sartre mais balzac tu sais même titre
c'est parce évidemment j'ai le cerveau
clotaire parce que je vous en avais on
avait tout simplement pas de nier
donc j'ai le plus tard en français tu as
aimé on a des lectures obligatoires de
space quittance toy pouchkine à
lermontov des grands poètes russes
donc c'est un mec de katia ils nous
avaient nous avait impressionnés qu elle
est vraiment elle est vraiment
incroyable cette femme et l'a d'ailleurs
il va ce pc dont ça en fait tu vois que
le caractère de la position un peu
changé donc on a plus maintenant
les structures de l'instinct diane lundi
elles sont les pions en c4 donc celle ci
suit encore une fois un cours typique
pour déstabiliser le centre est ce que
et sur ces quatre jumeaux je me pose la
question est-ce que voilà les noirs
comme je b5 tout de suite si ces quatre
étages de ces quatre des cinq pourquoi
il est saint et miner le centre tout
shit mais la capiale est en retard non
elle a fait cavalier c3e de revenus en
c3 est à l'impression que elle va être
enfin si elle prend deux fois avec des
pièces leur fout aussi cédé 5 voilà
c'est exactement ce que l'oubli dire qui
va arriver ça ressemble à ça peut
ressembler tu sais quoi à une nage dorff
maxime est ce qu a oui mais là c'est là
je me suis dit les blancs très en retard
c'est une tâche dorff maxime s quoi
c'est maxime avec les noirs la victime
et maxime avec les noirs c'est vrai il a
déjà une pièce à moi oui c'est le défaut
qu'elle est sur l'initiative
oui j'ai quand même envoyé totalité une
de voix c'est un peut cliquer au hasard
quoi avant mais parce que je me suis dit
le premier que de 5,7 une position
désespérée
sur le plan professionnel pour les
blancs les deux faux ici
entre les caves à l'aja ça que j'aime
bien ta g 5 c'est un bon coup et
heureusement qu'elle a trouvé le
cavalier 5,6 y avait pas caché 5 je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec toi c'est s
était mort je pense c'était quasiment
injouable en vrai c'est ce que voyant
que je vais des quatre je me suis posé
la question parce que je sais en fait je
n'analyse ses positions et de prendre
une partie classique tous ces jeunes
moaz j'avais de réfléchir et je me rends
compte que oui on commande ça va mais tu
vois là les pions doublé qui sont hyper
fort et peut-être dû d'un mach 4 qui
arrive pour mettre la pression sur f2
toute façon tu as pas grand rokia
tourcoing f2 tu es tellement en retard
ouais mais bon d'un autre côté comment
tu crées une menace avec les noirs parce
que j'aime bien ce que déjà tu vois tu
as la colonne f que tu contrôles
j'aurais aimé la tour ensuite aussi pour
en fait le vrai problème c'est que le
roi probablement va rester un à deux
points et linge et sèche le palais par
là ça me paraît très compliqué après je
vais je vais damage 4 je vais doubler
sur la colonne f je vais je pourrais
faire 3 certainement à manger j'aurais
peur je sais pas ça fait maintenant ça
fait peur mais je vais essayer de faire
un set up genre mettre le ronge et 2 le
pion f3a c'est un peu machine à tours fc
pas maxime essayer de fermer la porte et
tu vois je me suis dit la quête c'est un
coût humain et elle le joue qu'à tirer
nature parfois l ordinateur propose je
ne sais même pas ce que propose
l'ordinateur dans cette position-là
propose des décos qui ne sont pas
intuitif à 400 vaches ont séduit pas mal
ouais mais c'est quand même avec le plan
d'aller cacher le roi de l'autre côté
quoi oui est ce que tu peux espérer
genre b4 b3 et partirait mais le
problème de camp rock secte aura le pion
f2 qui y sera
sous pression oui pour le moment b4 ya
toujours fougueux 4 donc est ce que les
noirs doivent ouvrir encore un peu plus
la position de chip même à sacrifier le
port en bessin que je l'aurais pas
protégé ici donc il faut trouver un bon
moyen de couvrir
il ya un peu de réussite côté 4 parce
qu'elle est peut-être pas si mal
franchement ça aurait pu très mal
tourner et l'a peut-être tu peux prendre
b5 prendra huit férois eu deux jours de
salaire ouais ouais c'est ce que je
t'avais dressent encore une fois c'est
le plan qui est le plus naturel de
connecter les tours mais encore un tu
vois ce péon ses 2es faudra qu'on joue
ces trois mois va faire quelque chose et
quelque part elle est vraie différence
dans cette position c'est les faux le
fou en d2 est bien meilleur que le fond
un g7
c'est ce que j'étais en train de me dire
aussi je me demande s'il est noir
réussissent pas vraiment attaquer qu'on
rentre en finale elle peut être hyper
dur à jouer la finale pour les noirs
parce que le roi blanc il a le chemin
tout tracé avec du c3 vers le pion b5
oui donc là peut-être c'est trop comme
je l'avais dit auparavant mais je crois
que maintenant la tendance j'étais
complètement inversés et c'est pas mal
la pétition est ce qu'on peut faire même
roi des huns avec f3 c'est bizarre quand
même
roi des retours à 8 je me suis dit j'ai
regardé s'écoulait mais je me suis dit
rodern fera 8 et après tu auras un fossé
un flash 6 donc essayer de refaire droit
aux deux tours c'est 8 et répété oui
donc j'aime bien le roannais de est ce
qu ont juste 7 3 et 6 ou par non à dadis
et d'être joué tour siens peut-être dam
d'un psychiatre pourra changer les dames
et chez mais elle peut-être faire b 3
bets wahid dame des trois-rois détroit
ouais je pense que la finale aller dur
avec les noirs oui c'est bizarre comme
la partie à la tournée il ya on peut pas
vraiment détaché un mauvais coup des
noirs en fait ça ça tourner
progressivement
ouais c'est pas si évident tu vois un
encours les relations a complètement
changé et maintenant ils jouent tour à
un bien joué tour en russie et non
peut-être roi des huns maintenant
qu'elle a passé la tour aura bien est-ce
que je peux jouer peut-être tous les
fans de nouveaux rythmes jazz joseph iii
oui on va bientôt autorise fit je
voulais dire
bref trois regarde c'est ce qu'elle fait
elle sait ce qu'elle fait déjà
ouais c'est ce qu'elle joue jean noël
vient de jouer à rodez 1 j'imagine que
je voyais ça reste roi ici oui mais je
crois peut-être que seul
[Musique]
c'est une petite nuance soit la pause il
y avait déjà cherché damas huit c'est
pour ça que j'aimais pas et j'étais en
train de me poser la question en fait
pourquoi f3 pas de suite c'est pour ça
qu'il a joués h6 et toi mais non mais ça
oui en plus avec h6 elle gagne le tempo
sur le oui avait très bien joué voilà
elle joue vraiment bien et à la du fou
b4 qui rôdent aux siens wifo b4 et il ne
reste aux commandes tirées la dame la
demande d'être porte pour le moment ça
protège tout comme la position et fait
signer de la faire entrer tu fais trois
dames b3 tue ou même damas trois j'ai
l'impression qu'on va la passer soit sur
cette diagonale soit sur celle là non en
fait l'idée est complètement folle c'est
de jouer mon damas 3g 5 et beaucoup de
vide ce serait le seul coup et après
pour g7 ces dames et fut donc à huy
avait c'est là que tu voulais en venir
j'ai compris maintenant d'un coffret
voilà c'était ça l'idée
torah 5 et je pense elle veut sur tourbe
et sept tours à huit échecs peut-être et
fait ressortir le roi et on faisait
attention en année où est le temps donc
une minute par katia 1h30 pour erika qui
souffrent f3 ici c'est très bien
maintenant que l'autre prend 2,5 dans un
moyen non lv3 a donc droit ou deux
droits n 2 c'est parfait dans le rôle de
mère je me suis posé la question
peut-être qu'on pouvait sacrifier un f3
tu vois
parce que el cheikh al cheikh tu sais
elle aurait elle aurait dû jouer tour b
8 avant de reprendre la dame a à 20 c
est l ordinateur quel biais je sais pas
si c'est l'ordinateur qui le dit mais
j'étais en train de me dire que ça
l'avait fait tomber 8 avant y'avait
paroisse f7 non il faut et fait même
temps le foll est à 9,8 protégé par la
torre donc je me suis dit je transpose
un final de théo qui a complètement
laissé ça exactement
voilà elle a joué je pense qu'elle a
oublié royal 7 elle a joué rapidement
la vue l'idée elle s'est emmêlé les
pinceaux je pense ça arrive en bus quand
tu veux jouer vite et oui mais pour
achever de ces super mire joueurs aussi
comment tu veux arrêter
ouais mais l'autre à la une idée fin
arica pardon elle a une idée de défense
intéressant c'est qu'elle veut et chaque
échec en fait
ok mais tu re de donges et de revin tour
gérard wey f2 oui j'étais en train de me
demander comment on les perd la tour
j'avais foi h4 échec sur ce truc là oui
comment est-ce qu'on progresse dans et
c'est tout reprend g7 g5 et b4 mais ça
doit être nul ou g5 et une menace en ce
moment c'est ça le problème donc on peut
pas jouer en angleterre dans le ton et
je vais tourache 8 peut-être voyons des
vrais comme tu vas tour a chuté sur
cette tour ici brossé un jeune arabe
l'étroit ici c'est ok mais maintenant il
ya plus du tout le temps pour qu'un
tient en fait elle est complètement
folle elle est complètement nu j'ai dit
oh mon dieu oui oui c'est
malheureusement ils vont répéter mais
qu'est ce que s'est passé on a raté ce
moment critique où est ce que la dépense
sur tant de temps peut-être pour jette
toi je souhaitais trouver palais n'a pas
trouvé coup c'est dommage parce que je
suis sûr qu'elle avait l'idée avec tours
b 8
c'est sûr qu'elle l'avait est juste à la
joue et tempo option prend dame est vrai
cela elle a pas réfléchi au bon moment
katia parce qu'elle avait tous le plan
correct est l'inversé de coûts quoi -
oui donc la cécilienne avec g3 ce sont
les ouvertures que je connais très bien
j'ai essayé à peu près tout quoi
ce qui concerne
sicilienne 200 peut donc g3 s'éteint
c'est un cookie très malin c'est pour
pouvoir transposer dans plusieurs types
d'oppositions clal choisis sur cavalerie
6 2 5 2 5 et mais tu pouvais aussi je
vais détroit où que vous les c3 après je
vais d'éclat trop regarder même liberté
de jeu dans 3 des cas
donc il ya tellement d'autres non là c
est une position théorique c'est souple
quoi comme ouverture oui c'est une
ouverture très souple donc normalement
si tu prends un des 4 2 fois 2e des 4
montaut pose vraiment la question
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire avec le
connaître des cinq je vais ouvrir la
diagana jeu ses quatre tours d un c'est
pas une position facile et je vais
essayer de montrer un petit peu pour les
gens voilà juste pour voir ça j'essaie
donc rock
je dois rauque et aux jouets qualifié
ces préjugés autour d un choc et
étudiants 6 4 oui c'est une position que
j'aime bien donc oui les noirs ne joue
pas comme ça donc s attendre auprès des
quatre pour ça qu'ils sont obligés de
hockey est ce que tu sais comment katia
appelle le fou en g2 dans le chantier
tôt comme elle l'appelle à ses dires à
savoir elle l'appelle vlad junior
[Rires]
sachant que la catch up
l'avocat y était seulement son ami et
comité sur le fond j'ai 2 elle m'a sorti
ça il m'a dit c'est en fait c'est vrai
jean york
du coup elle aime bien vu avec le front
g2 katia aussi c'est vrai que c'est
solide ça ça consolide ton roi d'un côté
et en plus ça te permet d'attaquer
allèles dames c'est vraiment une pièce
une pièce forte influence y enquêter
oui sachant que c'est avec à quel point
je doit elle adopter le maître un jet de
sel se rend les gens
les ouvertures fermières de 3 2 3 et 4
là on a curieusement transposer dans une
position de la sicilienne avec ses 3 mai
avec le fonds en g2 fo 17 très bien joué
parce que je veux prendre pieds six
pouces et 6 et donc ses 4 tu vois tu
perds le tempo du jeu c'est c3 c4 mais
ce qu'avait le md5 qui est tout
simplement trop fois et je vais essayer
de le déloger et tu joue cavalier 3 par
la suite est sûr qu'il va lire ici c'est
peut-être des découvertes maintenant
qu'il faut en dix-sept auxquels ces six
fausses et 6 pour le moment ça protège
ça dépend si tu veux jouer cette
structure avec force et si ce que
laissait sieste faut cesser ce processus
voilà celle ci met à jour et c5
c'est pas ça j'ai appris ça il n'y a pas
très longtemps en fait que cette
structure n'a été pas trop grave pour
les moins avancés pensé que c'était bien
pour les blancs parce que les pions il
était isolé
l'inter c'est vrai contre ces trois
pions là c'est pas si grave oui surtout
c'est la case des quatre qui décisif
dans cette structure là si tu arrives à
échanger les fautes 15 noir est aussi
même transférer le cavalier des quatre
positions il est vraiment très dynamique
à ce que c'est quelque chose que j'aime
et que j'ai pas surprendre longtemps
qu'elle valait 2 7
sachant qu elle voulait pas et donc
lille b 5 mai un choix puisqu'elle fois
joué on n'a pas envie des faux plats
petit à petit en train s'il est noir
réussissent à leur attention fou 17 âmes
a joué un truc comme dam des six tours
des huit fouet 8 ils vont être bien mais
en même temps tu as eu si la case des
six qui est très faible donc lc3 j'aime
bien et je vais jouer fois f40 bonjour
oui oui c'est vrai à six qu'elle dessine
gp en baisse cette voie là on va voir ça
va jouer au tempo en vrai celui qui a
réussi en premier a et qui a aidé ici
c'est ce qu'on peut prendre et c'est de
cette jeune peut rapidement avec le
cavalier fut donnée la paire du fou
c'est trop dangereux non c'est pas trop
dangereux d'ailleurs parfois quand on
dans la perte de
c'est justifié par l'activité encore une
fois tu de tes pièces
la seule question est de savoir si tu
veux arriver à stabiliser les cavaliers
en d4
c'est aussi ça parfois on réfléchit sur
le long terme ça peut être concrètement
très bien là tout de suite mais après le
cannabis fait chasser du coup tu appuies
même j'ai gâché cinq
je regarde toujours ce pur 1 h 6 dans
cette position-là damage cinq mois déjà
je te mesurer vos yeux sont rivés sur le
pion à chier c'est d'ailleurs l'un sait
même pas si on peut le prendre à
sacrifier spéculatifs bonbons halal
c'est ouais c'est beaucoup mieux ce
qu'elle a fait katia de mettre le fou en
d4 de jouer 5 du coup elle s'est
stabilisée d'échangés et maintenant tu
as lattes hésite
est-ce que tu prend du plomb pour tenir
la case des quatre aux fans en jeu
repose aurait pris de la tour tout
simplement et pour cours des trois tours
des proies parce que j'ai toujours la
possibilité d'échanger lecavalier un
jour un cavalier de donc il faut d'abord
protéger les français 4 et après mais
moi aussi je veux jouer quatre des cinq
donc ces essais 5 b 4 on doit être un
peu juste visuellement mais ça pas j'y
réfléchirai kama à ces cinq ici et là
des cinq tout de suite à plusieurs
plaintes ses positions la somme pas
simple de jouer encore une fois parce
que c'est là on super plaisir si on
explique en fait la nature de l'erreur
parfois il ya trois plans qui ne semble
que maintenant il y en a un qui est bon
qui est moyen et un qui est mauvais -
c'est pas si évidente je dirais si on
peut donner un conseil si souvent il
faut choisir le plan qui qui plus simple
à jouer pour nous on se connaît ou
encore une fois on connaît notre propre
style et on sait voilà surtout ans
blessé il faut savoir il faudrait
envisager 23.9 ans quand même
il faut jouer la position dans laquelle
tu vas être le plus le plus à l'aise
salami latour ans et 8 et elle veut
jouer du tam du dam ces deux peut-être
est rentré tout simplement sur la
deuxième rangée un donc avait laissé
deux pour le moment c'était pas possible
parce qu'elle va tour ces trois oui
donc il y avait ensemble pouvait se
poser des questions mais pourquoi pas
les fourchette avec l'intermédiaire
cavaliers 3 mai donc c'était pas
possible dans des fiches et tu vois je
pense que maintenant le foin jeu 2 qui
bloquait pour sa part le plan des cinq
qui il est très passif
j'ai envoyé à toutes les pièces noires
fronsac sylvain toutes les pièces des
noirs sont actives et nord-est tour des
vite tu vois le dernier coup on va faire
jouer quatre brigades c'est sûrement
seul coin tu pouvais pas te permettre de
donner le pion b2 oui mais de votre côté
comment continuer d'entrer purement le 5
est un reprise
as tu pu ce déficit le parti j'aurais pu
tout est fondu avec la tour pour f 5 mai
et f5 eu quatre cavaliers f3 tu veux
dire tour 8 et 5 oui j'ai regardé le
coin 5 mais tu vas il veut jouer tour de
vis encore une fois tu vois tu joues
avec les maïs et tu va placer les pièces
sur les cases tu estimes tu es mal donc
depuis longtemps je crois qu'elle a
planifié sokoto des rites
j'ai l'impression qu'à ricm fort qu'elle
préparait elle peut pas garder cette
structure de pions trop longtemps
j'imagine qu'elle doit jouer avec 4 à un
moment donné et joue un peu le tout pour
le tout quoi déstabiliser le pion de 5
et le cavalier des 4 4 là il vient jouer
dam des trois virtù tard elle va être
obligée d'envoyer f4 et j'étais en train
de me demander si je pouvais transposer
je sais pas avec qui tu veux protéger le
pion si je joue cavalier 5
est-ce que ça c'est possible à tour j'ai
quatre peut-être après la prison
non tu veux qu'elle va laissant michael
bay ça que je calcule et 15 mai cinq
dames bessac peut-être à tour bétourné
en tout de suite
attends je voulais pas d'accord du tout
rejet capelle sûr que c'était son idée
mais je trouve que katia mal joué la
dernière série de coups la f6 tour des
huit cavaliers f5 ça devient dangereux
maintenant se remplir à jack avait levé
7 exactement pour couvrir la case
justice je voyais pas d'autre qu'au sens
et tu as tête des cinq en même temps
qu'est ce qu'elles font jouer
franchement celle de tourbe et quatre
tours d1 c'est possible et oui mais en
même temps est-ce qu'on peut exploiter
la faiblesse des 5 5 m en coin
dams et 5 peut-être qu'il y avait eu
lieu quatre que vnf six mois là c'était
celle des blancs regarde je reviens
juste un coup en arrière
c'est très curieux et là je me suis dit
pourquoi pas d'am-dam c5
le dal 5 et quel est le 4e vérifier ça
près ouais tu es d'abord prise à non
quand même des simples ou alors j'ai pas
visible en cavalier de sa voix laisse à
protéger même si ce donc je sais pas du
tout et ça a pu être à ça c'est genre de
truc qui peut être raté aussi en parler
oui d'accord sans partition que ça
pouvait être l'idée est juste que ça
marchait pas mail un petit à petit c'est
en train de se retourner une nouvelle
fois parce que maintenant le cavalier e
set
il est plus lent des quatre où il était
super bien placé et puis on dessins
qu'il est bien défendu et peut-être un
jour il ya qui avait lieu 4 et des six
qui arriva ce qui est intéressant c'est
que la plus grosse différence dans les
deux matches on voit ce que fait qu'on
en a déjà gagné deux et je vais les
parties comprennent malades dont ils
tentaient le tout pour le tout dans
disco arica elle allie les coups
offensifs avec les coupes défensif et je
pense que katia elle a du mal pour le
moment de s'adapter à ce site et la wave
1 sacrifie pas tout tout de suite c
allez allez plus complet tariqa en fait
elle joue les coups elle joue la
position en fait tariqa elle
elle peut jouer très tactique mais elle
peut aussi jouer des coups tranquille
des coups de défense c'est une joueuse
beaucoup beaucoup plus forte pour man
bleed 5,1 à nakheel ajoutant que ceux-ci
connaissent vraiment surprise sur joue
rarement sa position très complète mais
là je pense que raymond réputé
l'écoulement je pensais à roissy ce
qu'avait laissé cette merveille cette
bière jouer là ça je vous le gardez de
côté 1
c'est terrible je sais pas qui est mieux
j'ai du mal à te j'ai du mal à savoir
qui de protéger mais bon on a un point
de plus que les 8,5 impôts aussi qu'il
peut échapper de notre champ de vision
c'est bien joué ça qu'ils avalent eric
et publicis mais du coup vrai nom c'est
peut-être je prendrais plutôt les blancs
maintenant parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'on va mettre p 3 enfin bon il ya
presque plus de temps
il ya quand même le pion b3 qui est un
peu plus loin
non non mais là mais objectivement c'est
une position chennai légal je ne peux
toujours pas fait la cia vraiment moyen
de gaffer parce que si tu échanges les
cavaliers même pas qu'ils adhéraient
catherine nay la 2e à 2 secondes
ouais c'est pour ça et je ne sais pas
qui voilà les pions sai son parti je
pense ça gagne pour harry gaza 5pourquoi
par my child of alors ils vont arrêter
les pions quand même oui mais là oui
elle va trouver les cavaliers h7l va
essayer de trouver le coup corey locke
est annoncé avec valeo 4 regarde à la
récupération gestation font fait très
bien match nul c'était passionnant tu
m'avais les portiers comme si je les
jouais à moi même
bon on a encore le perdre ce film de
surf classique classé que ça veut dire
annonce cette fois il faut être trois à
six
ce qu'elle va jouer un système avec ces
trois noms je le disais en partie parce
que j'ai pas vu les vertus remettre ça à
transposer 16
parce que moi je laisse que cavaler un
g8 et avec à 6 g jour le plan orsec
oui d'esker et cas elle préfère invoquer
tout de suite elle se prépare contre 7
et des fourrages 6 aussitôt que les fous
de protéger donc on va pas prendre à 9,6
notamment voyons se laisser prendre pour
monter le roi et contrôler les gaz noir
il va attaquer au fait l'idée de
roquettes ou de suite c'est d'attaquer
le centre soit 5 5 4 moi j'ai toujours
du mal à jouer ses positions là avec les
blancs c'est y aller les noirs ont trop
de manière d'attaquer le centre je
n'arrive pas tout les anticiper mais je
te comprends mais en fait quand j'ai les
jours le souvent avec les noms je te
conseille de le regarder aussi de votre
côté j'ai l'impression que je suis perdu
à chaque fois avec les deux couleurs du
coup oui avec les deux couleurs donc
c'est pas si il est bien encore une fois
pourquoi on a du mal de les jouer avec
les blancs parce qu'on n'a pas de
d'objectifs très définis dans le centre
du centre et elle n'est pas défini c'est
pour ça qu'on a du mal à les jouer
on doit s'adapter c'est une sorte d sort
ouais tu peux pas tu vas tu sais pas si
ça va venir par cinq ans à venir par ces
cinq par b 5 b 4 et du coup il faut
savoir jouer d'un coup structurés oui là
tu vas sans nuance et 4 ça se transpose
de verre une espagnole avec j'y suis
maintenant sélestadienne attend est ce
que c'est une bonne estonienne ah si tu
prends penser si ça sera pas
catastrophique mais c'est très cool pour
les noirs c'est pas mal mais tu es
obligé de prendre quand même pour aller
pour wii pour avoir cette faiblesse en
des sièges mais je
je pense que c'est une position à peu
près équilibré je sais pas quelle
couleur je prendrais honnêtement
peut-être sûrement les blondes ce que je
joue pas avec les noirs mais oui
j'aurais du mal à évaluer j'aurais du
mal à savoir aussi qui est mieux
paraison ça doit être proche de
l'égalité mais encore une fois tu es là
si on compare la cécilienne kalachnikov
ont aussi blesse en ce moment le four ne
s'étaient quand on joue avec avec le
foin j'essaie de c'est pas le même type
d'opposition mais non je jouais cinq
aussi la référence c'est bien contre les
tours 8 c'est bizarre visuellement pour
moi comme pour pascale senk tout de
suite n'était pas possible mais je pense
qu'elle voulait pourquoi je transfère
lofo âme et du couffo âge si ça peut
faire mal non et oui non parce que tu
veux pas forcément et tu vois échangés
so foot ça doit être quelque chose
d'extrêmement concret vous êtes juste eu
à gagner dès 6 ans mais tu veux dire que
même si tu gagnes des si ce n'était pas
si grave parce que c'est un sacrifice
positionne à la fête fut écrite je vais
prendre avec le cavalier sur dame des
six dans l'absolu je veux protéger le
pion et après je vais jouer
le cavalier je vais jacques a valu six
cavaliers des 4 je comprends l'homme oui
c'est un sacrifice positionnelle qui
existe dans toutes les ouvertures
je pense qu'elle veut pas prendre moi je
joue quand même parce qu'elle voulait
quand même joué h4 je pense qu il a
regardé on à la petite jauge de lord il
alors dit montre une tactique très jolie
regarde et qu'est ce qui se passe tout
reprend des systèmes prend des six
cavaliers h5 os très gêné c'est très
trouvable avec trois minutes 50 à la
pendule si c'est vrai et sur cavalleri
cissé l'a pas vu que je suis 5e c'est ça
ouais c'est une très jolie position mais
il fallait qu'on calcule ses cinq ou six
quel dommage d'avoir raté ça c'est femme
quand tu sais qu'il ya quelque chose
évidemment c'est beaucoup plus facile
mais alors et si on lui avait dit alors
est clairement trouvé et on peut pas
recommencer avec genre cavaliers g5
thorax et ça c'était pour prendre
l'échangé refaire qui valait à j-5 après
les médailles
la dame serait protégé pour le moment
n'empêche
en fait encore une fois si parfois c'est
cette position là bien évidemment son
très joli c'est une illusion optique
quand on la regarde du côté de blanc tu
vois on a ce centre qui est contrôlé le
maroc c'est bine les taux demain roxy
donc les quatre c4 mien il suffit de
rater un coût et il évolue si on change
là ça y est ça remarche encore plus fort
parce que sûr qu'elle va lui aussi s'il
vous prend aussi cela normalement elle
va le voir là c'est très haut autant au
cou avant c'était un petit peu dur
autant la cavale et h5 c'est quand même
assez simple un bal trouver cardiaque et
h5
voilà bien chez sas est immédiatement
j'ai prendre cinq dames prend des 6es
regarder je sais que t'as pas le retour
caméras mais elle a bu un petit peu de
thé ou d'eau oui oui c'était sa boisson
magique le temps l'écart les quarts de
finale où l'attend le teich well as
lycée qu'elle a gagné c'est parce qu'on
voit le score
le score y avait 2 1 pour arica et ça va
faire deux encore une fois tu vois j'ai
parfois je ne suis pas très objective
ici dans cette position là parce que je
joue souvent un côté noir quand il faut
un maître cornette notre et mon
entraîneur et notre entraîneur notre
sélectionneur
il a écrit un livre magnifique sur des
siciliens de kalachnikovs et du coup on
s'est mis tout pour tous à jouer dessus
si bien que la chenille coiffe avec ces
structures là où le plan des six est
souvent faible mais un chat offrant un
jeu tellement dynamique alors attends
ils font une petite pause ils font une
petite pause après je ne sais pas trop
pourquoi mais une pause après après la
moitié du 5 du 5 + ans il ya un genre de
petit imitant parti comme dans les
tournois de poker c'est ça c'est ça
55e minute on va se reposer cinq équipes
j'ai trouvé moi personnellement katia
quand même légèrement plus forte en ce
début de match ça confirme un peu ce
qu'on pense et toi qu'est ce que qu'est
ce que t'en as pensé à amira jeu qui ce
qui me surprend c'est quand même parce
que cinq ans et c'est une tendance qui
est encore une fois n'est pas si rapide
il ya trop de gaffes pour moi pour le
moment tu vois c'est peut-être ya trop
d'occasions ratées même pour le blitz
parce que je démens les pièces volées
dans le bol est même le 3 et est ce que
j'ai remarqué aussi dans le match
précédent c'est curieux que serena est
une joueuse absolument exceptionnelle il
avait ce blind spot je sais pas comment
on appelle ça un français tu vois elle
restait souvent les coups de cavaliers
allez tous les goûts les mannequins qui
a mené cette sas et c'est que c'est
quand même des gars assez simple
maintenant par exemple élevé la dame de
ciel
l'adversaire avait le cavalier insistant
que je donnais salle écoute cavaliers
dames de huit échecs hills est arrivé
assez souvent
donc je me suis dit il ya quelque chose
à te lèves 2 c'était la fourchette après
il a joué dames 6 elle a donné sa dame
pendant trois coups quand le kelly est
un des quatre oui oui il y avait il y
avait quelque chose qui m'a vraiment
surpris je lui dis même après mais
qu'est ce qui se passe avec les jeux
c'est en fait la stratégie la parfaite
stratégie pour les blessés tels que je
n'ai de terminer pour moi même raconté
pas en forme si c est sa [ __ ] voilà pour
tout le monde j'ai c'est d'échanger les
cavales est à 7 1 pour être sûr de rien
rater et si on veut des rayons raté
parce que je sais que j'y panique c'est
quand elle me reste quelques secondes
moi je peux tout rater au moins des
décharges et en cavale et peu importe
même comme très le faut pour être sûr de
bien voir tout ce qui se passe moins
quand je suis pas en forme j'oublie des
trucs complètement stupide mais ça peut
être avec n'importe quelle pièce c'est
pas vraiment de cavale et si tu peux me
proposer un échange de dame je peux
l'oublier
je suis content moi je vous dis ça
dépend peut-être des automatismes je
sais dit lecavalier est une pièce
tellement de dayraut tente et je suis
encore hanté par la fourchette dans mon
premier tournoi que j'ai joué avec un
coussin sur la chaise et mon adversaire
est lui resté un cavalier et quelques
pions et donc j'ai perdu cet anti calage
j'avais 6 ans ah bah oui bien de métier
et s'intéresse t oui ça m'est resté
je me pose la question sur la mémoire
d'un joueur d'échecs sur les
traumatismes s'est passé là elle
intéresse elle te reste à vie il me
reste à vivre
les cavaliers sont tous voila c'est
toujours aussi dangereux
je sais pas moi tu vois geslin c'est
très marrant quand je suis pas en forme
je suis vraiment capable de voir un truc
comme fou ces quatre tours des six tours
prend cavale et h5 vite mais je t'assure
que l'adversaire proposerait un échange
de damas un moment donné je suis
vraiment capable d'oublier mais pas
réveillère qui viennent parce que rien
que pour as pour regarder non d'un match
de volley foot c'est ça que j'avais
l'impression quand même que les noirs ce
je sais pas quelle va lui aussi j'ai
compris après y'avait cavaliers fils
comme alain et demain non quand elle a
joué ses cinq donc quand elle est ratée
j'avais l'impression que les noirs
pouvaient s'en sortir ce que tu voyais
c'était une sorte de trêve elle a joué
ses cinq tours 6-3 on peut regarder avec
lord il alors dit donner quoi ils
donnaient des ces poussées 4 et qui a
validé 4è mais bon ça va durer parce que
je me disais tout s'est passé tellement
vite que j'avais l'impression qu'il me
restait que jouit je pouvais jouer
qu'avec les d4 effectivement ça simple
très bon sacrifice de qualité est là le
cavalier g3 il est complètement nul
parce qu'il est dans le pion le fou il
attaque le pion b3 et les blancs sont
complètement dominés mais ça c'est pas
si simple à trouver
makelele des caps quand même c'est un
oui en courant j'ai déjà évoqué le
sacrifice de qualité dans ses positions
de pointe donc je me suis dit il a
complètement raté ce tdr et cas mais tu
vois même main g j'essaye de trouver
cette vérité absolue mais revint dans
l'oubli tout s'est passé tellement vite
je voulais absolument savoir parce que
quand je regardais la position je
n'arrivais pas à calcul est vite fait je
me suis dit il ya quelque chose de
bizarre qui se passe certes oui les
cavaliers des quatre fois que tu l'as vu
ses frappes en kz et fort oui donc et
surtout fois c'est ce qu'avait f prend
1,6 g vengerait plus c'est bien tant les
deux balles et deux tu vas leur didonne
les deux en fait je voyais en fait oui
j'ai un vrai bon j'ai un soucis avec ma
vue ces derniers temps j'ai
j'ai maintenant que je vois très bien
les chéquiers parce qu'elle est beaucoup
plus grand j'ai du mal
c'est petit mais il donne les deux mains
au début il pensait fou prend aussi
signe maintenant ils pensent qu a valu
au 6 mai a maintenant il dit équivalent
me donne moins de 50
et c'est sûr que les deux sont jouables
c'est la peine donc sur qu'avaient les
faits c'est ce que j'aurais joué
spontanément qu'avaient les cinq je peux
pas prendre le plan où il ya quelque
chose qui perd un set suite cavalières
et cavaliers ces données on sait ça
swingue ça va pas là pour les blancs
mais tu vois donc que cette position-là
offre d'un encore une fois des des
possibilités extraordinaires mik
donc même si on s'est créé chez la
qualité sont mieux tout simplement mais
je suis d'accord
un ricain qui a oui qui est un petit peu
raté quoi qui est un petit peu ratée qui
a raté sa chance à temps remettre la
bonne caméra parce qu'à la chance a
comme elle a changé ses caméras et
combien ah oui parce que qu'elles sont
d'ailleurs les les contraintes pour les
joueuses
donc ils doivent avoir deux caméras
ouais elles ont deux caméras et tu vois
rigoler tout le temps tout sourire ouais
c'est agréable on a craqué et a quatre
enfants comme katia encore une fois elle
en a inscrit ce que tu sais si elle est
un enfant arricau pas et n'ont elles pas
dedans forme pour le moment doctrine que
tu es déjà je pense que d'avoir un
moment elle où tu peux juste comme
bronstein 6 7 de ce soir devant l'échec
et dix minutes avant la partie pour en
acheter une neuve
ce rituel il arrive bien sûr sur
l'échiquier
dix minutes avant la partie je fermais
les yeux et c'est bon et essayer de
rentrer dans cette étape de
concentration peut être d'autres 36 même
tu sais qui nécessite une partie
d'échecs
donc je pense que katia rien que d'avoir
un moment l2
de ne pas être sollicités tout le temps
on a fait un stream ensemble le même des
streams semblent si sur une chaîne russe
et il ya ces êtres sans fils c'est mon
adorable qui venait regarder le direct
c'est complexe mais c'est vraiment
complexe hélas et je suis content pour
elle elle s'est qualifiée pour les pour
les candidates
oui j'espère qu'elle va qu'elle va
réussir à prendre le temps et à se
qualifier parce que là les quatre essais
c'est une autre encore une autre
structure de cette ouverture j'ai jamais
parlé juste juste avec elle est fidèle
encore une fois sa préparation pour ce
match donc katia elle a changé
jouer des 5 et 6 mai s amènent leurs
structures là donc à la date qu'elle est
bête 3 un peu la française mais avec la
fois un jeu de je trouve que c'est
toujours difficile de jouer contre le
pion isolé avec le pion ces deux plutôt
que deux je préfère c'est le jouer comme
ça avec le pion aux trois là je me sens
très confortable avec le pion en c3 je
me sens jamais bien avec les blancs à
cause de ce fonds un imbécile
voyez toujours très généré 3 par rapport
à la française le fou et des antennes à
2 2 3 les fois où je dois le mérite
d'attaquer le plan des cinq mais je
pense que cette position encore une fois
il ya un siècle les brèches qu'avaient
les quatre est un plan typique majorité
où ça ici elle va peut-être mettre la
dame en f6 apprécié cavalli bougies plus
hardis qui avait plongé trois j'ai
toujours l'impression qu'avec les blancs
c'est difficile à jouer enfin encore une
fois combien dans la française le lait
des stratégiques s'est dé changer les
fous de cases noires il sait pas si
simple donc je dois je vais fou à 3 que
va laisser de propos vraiment dans cette
position-là l'univers du quai branly
droite ultra brite
voilà près h3c ce que je voulais dire
parce que d'habitude on n'a pas cette
position là parce que le prg de lifou et
franck des trois rouennais de après h
trois fois trois quarts aile et je crois
même peut-être il faut qu mettre le fou
en f4 mais du coup tu conteste pas cette
diagonale et c'est pénible à jouer
non c'est pas si mal je me dis d'un des
trois avec vous et 3 d'ailleurs je pense
non c'est un bon coup dans le détroit
pour protéger le fond on est trop
apprécié de les échanger dans les
françaises ça se passe comment quand on
joue au foot ou trois parfois en et
charges mais parfois on transfère le fou
en ce 7 mai là tu vois encore y'a pas
cette idée de fou c'est cette dame
d'hesdin 9,6 g 5 donc ici il faut jouer
plutôt de façon positionnelle donc d'un
méfier c'est un très bon gouffre 3 et
voilà la belle a bien joué les deux
derniers coups de riga sont en forme
mais j'aime parce que je me pose la
question si si je dirige a vu cette
position puisque j'ai analysé ces gens
là je pense que c'est une position
théorique
j'ai vu quelques parties où les blancs
monts jury donne des trois forêts 3
maintenant je me souviens de calais 7
c'est intéressant se place j'aurais joué
que 17 tours de 8
donc j'ai pas compris le biais duquel
les 7 et protège les pertes des 5
probablement un 22 quai vallet cède
c'était peut-être celles aidées des
blancs donc il ya toutes les pièces sur
l'échiquier le pion isolé c'est pas
c'est pas une faiblesse très importante
mais c'est vrai que si les blancs
réussissent à échanger les fous puis les
cavaliers oui il se fit de boîtes de
deux échanges et encore une fois tu vas
cette position là elle n'a pas de
caractère concret tu vas y si on peut
faire un coup par coup on sait quels
sont les aider dans cette nature là et
en oeuvre tout simplement donc avec les
5 à 9 5 et tu vois qu'est ce qui se
passe ici sur d'amd 5 je prends g3 je
pense je prends g35 va prendre 17 je
sais pas sur dame des cinq mois j'ai 2
c'est pas possible donc si tu dois être
et pourquoi à rien j'ai 3 mai avec je
sais pas je pense avec cela
la dame des sept tours des huit
cavaliers enfin je sais pas c'est très
très honnêtement c'est très tactique ça
m'étonnerait qu'elle est tout calculer
un sa boîte au feeling oui jo fenech et
encore une fois c'est toujours cette
position [ __ ] je sais de pelé possible
soit tu reprends des 5 es tu calcules
une suite très concrètes a souhaité il
doit faire quelque chose avec tong est
en baisse de 7,3 honnêtement bonjour et
le feeling que dame prend des cinq d'un
avantage blanc mais bon la gérer un
calcul et on commente un j'en sais rien
mais j'aurai un bon feeling battant l
avion elle vient d'envoyer leurs noms
jalal vient d'envoyer d'un prend des
cinq lors didonne égale d'amd 5e gala
qu'elle évolue leur sacre lors
d'identiques voix c'est tour maladroite
je voulais le mentionner je n'ai pas
vraiment compris ses positions de tours
elle voulait probablement protéger le
pion à 2 ouais garder la tour en f1 et
le touran et en os qu'il ya des
possibilités de ce manhwa toutes les
pièces blanches relief si c'est une très
mauvaise elle a pas vu que mal et je
crois donc tu proposes et cavaliers quel
jeu trois cavaliers où je crois au canal
sport je pense cavalier e mais d'un pont
17 en fait je voyais rien
peut-être qu'on pouvait prendre la tour
non base du loup ce qui surprend il
prend 20 et l'ordi disait quoi à temps
l'ordi prenez de l'autre pour chaque
année oui effectivement et prendre b2
voilà c'était sa possession la wii avec
une compensation et elle l a fait
cavalier fils et maintenant dame b3
évidemment la scellé
blanc qui sont beaucoup mieux puisqu'ils
ont juste un pion de plus en lui parce
que cavaler g3 tué l'intermédiaire d'un
v6 est simplement donc ici qu'est ce
qu'il faut garder les dames il faut j'ai
dans mon avis oui mais maintenant on a
juste un peu moins
et alors d'amchit 7 avec les dés de
prendre un g3 maintenant que tu as dame
à terme des 3 il faut essayer de ses
positions encore une fois on prend le
risque ça ça doit pas marcher mais on
blitz qui s'éveille humble et encore une
fois c'est ce que je voulais dire que
c'est même dans l'ouverture parfois on
utilise des et des sujets qui est qu'ils
perdent en ligne mais où il faut trouver
vraiment de cette cour voyons c'est pas
du jouer simple dames ces deux dames f2
échanger les dames dncd j'aurais joué
peut-être à foisches 3 d'un match de
tout de suite en cavale et 1,4 à 1,8 à
peut-être qu'il va lieu 4 après il n'y a
pas une suite complètement fou et je
crée chez tous et jason fouache 3 et
cavaliers e24 lieu de assez sympa comme
coup et comment continuer maintenant
sept mètres ce qui a valu ont des cartes
est allié avec des cas très regroupée
oui les pièges africain va des f4 si
elle peut et qu'elle n'est donc une
minute mais tu sais agricole lui reste
qu'une minute que thierry nat 2 minutes
donc je pense que tout est possible un
cavalier fdk très bien je vais les
scènes de red rocket sens qu'avant ces
pièces est réelle menace d'un pro b c
est aussi un pour revenir comme ça
en gagnant à vue au passage
1 cave elle est ou quatre noms à on a
l'impression que ça tue ça parce que
kovalev des quêtes très bien joué mais
parce qu'elle ouvre aussi le coroner
dans le sud ont même envisagé du
tourcoing est fils d'un premier set même
si je l'aurais pas fait mais tu vois
j'aime bien dans le sac parce qu'elle
peut jeu de mach 5 transférer 16h03
toujours hors jeu non mais c'est sûr que
c'est bien jouer c'est sûr que c'est un
très bon coup dams et 5 pour pour mettre
de la pression et d'ailleurs et garde
qu'à raqqa elle réfléchit toujours tours
fc 5 rabelais sacrifier la qualité voilà
les mêmes réflexes que moi nous oui mais
du coup elle à l aqua est là elle a
quatre pions contre quatre elle a essayé
de simplifier un peu la position c'est
ce qu'il s'est dit tu vois quand j'ai
dit est là elle a décidé qu'elle serait
la position qui est plus simple pour
elle et qui sera plus simple pour elle a
joué avec très peu de temps après tu
sais qu'il ya des pièges de fougères un
coup que tu as envie de jouer c'est tour
f1 il ya tout reprend 2,2 oui ça c'est
genre de genre de coups que tu peux
jouer tour f1 en effet jamais trois oui
tour d'ebitda maaf 3 et larminat saddam
à la nage ou des très bons coups
l'américain ya tout qu'est-ce qu'il faut
jouer sur d'un g5 la foulée 5 j'aime
bien ça joue sur les clous hcc avec 30
secondes à la pendule c'est pénible à 3
h un bien joué aussi je trouve
merveilleux tour gère maintenant
j'arrive
ouais ouais non mais ça va ça va
probablement gagner à les obliger de
prendre à elle doit peut-être prendre à
eux deux qui avait pris eux deux et
tours troyes ou dame e3 pour essayer de
tableau et changer les dames en fait
avec les noirs et essayer de jouer la
pendule quoi oui mais il ya trop de
pions si tu avais juste les plans à deux
buts de huy
faut être 2-2-2 c'est sa c4 pour
décembre mais la tour g1 c'est hyper
faire je pense à gagne sur le champ au
roy ait fuité d'un point f6 non ouais
jouer oui malheureusement
comment 26,7 lectorat je crois cette
période qu'est les deux simples avec si
peu ton à la raison de l'ajout et un
katia mais bon n'oublions pas qu'on en a
comme un une seconde d'agrément et oui
ça ne permet pas encore une fois la qui
avait lui aussi ce joli terminé bien
joué à ricains belle partie
elle a vraiment dominé ans la joueuse
indienne et tu vois à quel point elle a
très bien décrit tu as dis que c'est pas
si évident de jouer avec nos pions
isolées soient bons jeux elle a joué des
coups très simple j'ai finalement avec
cette ouverture là et la lie à jouer
dans d'étroits faut y croire c'était le
plan stratégique
oui oui à la joue et un plan elle a joué
un plan simple efficace et katia elle a
pas réussi à la fée son cavalier 7 qui
était étrange et et dès qu'on l'a vu ce
qui a valu cette n'a pas pu vraiment
compris à quoi il servait oui j'aurais
joué fou 17 tours de 8 mais oui je fais
brûler peut-être voulu éviter qu'après
que va laisser 2 je sais que le club des
5 soit un prisme et peut-être peur
profonde et 7 tours de 8
on peut sacrifier finalement elle n'a
pas joué de manière assez active avec
son pion isolé ce que non c'est un jeu
très dynamique avec le pion isolée et
elle n'a pas elle a pas réussi à créer
ce dynamisme est donc là on allait
le mâle système de karo kann qu'elle à
caracas ses trois collègues trois jeux
je vois la position maintenant quiet way
ça c'est toujours ce genre de position
comme joue des foules à carreaux canet
la scandinave depuis que je suis gamin
j'ai l'impression que c'est toujours
égal mais je d'état jouer ça avec les
noirs jouent ses positions là depuis
toute ma vie et à chaque j'en ai marre
de les voir quand j'ai les noirs je ne
supporte plus en fait j'en sais que tu
peux jamais être mieux en fait tu sais
oui c'est ça c'est ça décret c'est
justement le sentiment qu'en quand la
grande ouvrit comme ton jeu cette
position là mais ce qui ce qui est
intéressant c'est encore une fois c'est
c'est une ouverture de compte
oui accepte d'être moins bien mais t'as
pas de faiblesse a encore une fois
positionné
oui mais c'est au studio pour dix ans tu
joues pendant très longtemps
non mais tu joues pendant très longtemps
il faut être extrêmement patient dans
ses ouvertures la halle et les blancs
vont essayer de prendre le plus d'espacé
possible mais encore une fois tu as eu 5
c'est une idée très typique pour cette
voiture là et j'étais en 32 buts en 32
la calculer je me disais est ce que
c'est trop tomba hockey ici quintal
avion prendrait cattrall a bien calculé
à s'inquiéter faut calculer la suite
c'est peut-être 2.3 que c'était au tour
des huit noms et ça marche tu allais le
connaissez peut-être parce qu'elle a
joué vraiment vite assez la suite dans
la partie dresser la partie d'accord
mais je pense qu'après tour des rites
[Musique]
avec prise en béton elle va pouvoir
prendre le dessus sur échec et prendre
b2 vrai mais bon il y aurait cavaliers à
5 est ici système
oui mais les morts n'ont pas de problème
normalement dans cette position-là donc
et encore une fois avec une perspective
sur le long terme de
gagner le plan c'est de ça dont je
prendrais plutôt les noirs ou si je suis
d'accord avec toi la tour qui arrive en
b2 quand même ça peut être un atout est
ce qu'on prend un f2 intermédiaire au
pain je me suis posé la question
encore une fois très naturel de prendre
la jouer là je pense qu'on prend b2 et
qu'on la sait ça l'fait cavalia qui a
valu à 5 ça m'étonne parce que si les
blancs jouent b4 basse et le coup
qu'elle fut d'ailleurs le pion c'est ici
ça va être une faiblesse à long terme à
elle le donne comme ça oui ça c'est une
est bénéfique des joueurs de grandes
fêtes cajou katrina mais aussi dans
curieusement avait avec un peu plus de
fantaisie qu'on a dans la catalane ah
oui oui ce genre de chose mais avec les
couleurs inversées donc voilà c'est ça
qui est torse 8
mais est ce que c'est soutenu par le
calcul dr f 5
je peux prendre 5 / cavalli b3 tu peux
prendre b3 et prendre les prendre des
trois j'ai l'impression aïe c'est une
très jolie tactique ouais tu as tout à
fait raison
parfois il existe 6 7 et des 2 reprendra
avec le cavalier ces cinq ans
ce qu'on peut jouer de suite y assiste
ici c'est dangereux
en fait je en train de dire que la
variante c'est en france et 5 tours
prend 1,55 à rehissé 6 mais je sais pas
comment il va lui et ça mais je prendrai
des blancs parce qu'il ya le fou qu'on
le tueur fou contre tours cavaliers tu
as tout reprendre sans qu'ils s'y
mettent a obligé de jouer des tours à
huit mois est de protéger une des tours
je sais pas quel tour encore une fois
dans cette variante malgré dix ans
probablement il faut garder la tour 1
oui sur les huitièmes bien joué mais le
fou était bien meilleur dans cette
position là ils dominent d'opposition
donc on va jouer peut-être a4 a5 a6 un
bloc est fixé ce point à 7
elle bouge tout rien 5
mais je suis pas si sûr parce que les
besoins de deux tours dans cette
position là quand même
je vais mettre les tours en bessette et
je vois pas comment il pourrait avec les
noirs j'ai un plan assez clair je vais
jouer vingt sept cavaliers décès trois
des six qui avait laissé cinq effet joué
exactement de cette façon là donc tour b
sides qu'elle 17 25 tour c'est cette
même mais trois des quatre c4
tu peux mais tu penses que c'est pas
suffisant pour viol avantage si c'est
sûr mais cet implant encore une fois qui
est très intéressant et je dois
peut-être si j'amène mon roi un décès
seulement tu joues c'est 4g fait il faut
que je dirais oui faut que j'arrive de 5
elle va mettre le cavalier en russie ce
peut-être oui voilà maintenant mais je
me disais sur trois des quatre cavaliers
aussi séché qui avait complètement raté
c'est ok j'avais complètement ratée
l'idée fait jeu j'avais l'impression que
les noix enfin en n'envoyant pas cette
défense de cavaliers ou six
semblait difficile et on le voyait en
fait du coup y'a pas de problème pour
pour les noirs et oui le puits on achète
dans cette position là un bon après
noble bv dont on pouvait jouer je suis
c'est probablement poursuivi tout
racheter ça me rappelle aussi cette
portier de 1 2962 étudiants fischer il a
pris en hd mais quelle qu'elles brahms
et est prêt je pense que le monde entier
se demander mais pourquoi il a pris ce
pillage 2 on s'est toujours pas
d'ailleurs mais on sait toujours pas
d'air on saura ne sera jamais en réalité
mais gégé ugg lune
une version que fisher pensé que c'était
pas perdants et qui voulait prouver à ce
parce qu'ils qui pouvait même faire nul
dans cette finale contre lui mais je ne
sais pas quel point à 87 6 est véridique
c'est véridique non je sais pas mais
j'ai lu cette explication qui m'a paru
tu sais qui m'a semblé être la plus
logique au final la plus convenable mais
je sais pas à quel point c'est vrai tu
attendais set j'aurais pas jouer parce
que j'aime c'est déjà commencé encore
une fois on me dira que j'aime bien la
position de benoît parce que je sais que
tu fais tous les coups et je voulais
garder la tour parce que maintenant que
tous les pions sont sur les cases
blanches g7
je suis sage 7,5 le fou est bien plus
fort même si l'ordinateur un peu évoluer
ses positions comme les gars je pense
que si bien que difficile de les jouer
avec les noirs mais moi je les tiens tu
vois moi j'aurais préféré avec les
j'aurais préféré la jouer avec les noirs
tu assez marrant parce que je
je me serais bien jouer il fallait si tu
échanges les tours a cité chance du
droit oui oui oui d'accord oui j'aurais
100% d'accord avec toi way
100% d'accord et que soir et j'aurais
plutôt garder les tours aussi avec les
noirs et c'est pour ça que j'étais
surprise que tirer n'a pas échangé le
tour est la plus haute estime que la
tour est très actif tu sais un sur les
métiers il peut pas prendre un accès
plus simple ici donc il ya sept points
tactiques sur laquelle probablement un
compte et arica je sais comme tête
défendre cette position la tortue 8
commence à perdre en un peu le fil de la
partie et je pensais tu mets mon tour
bessette c'est tout à fait possible mais
les tours b 5 c'est pas mal pour tour
des singles pour bloquer un peu ouais
mais le père ses deux j'ai pas vu ce que
ça a lâché 3 des 4 cavaliers à trois c4
oui et en plus cavalier à trois ça
arrive avec une menace sur la tour c'est
terrible donc elle est ratée que revêt
lé 5
elle a perdu le fil et met tout de suite
et on a tous les deux senti qu'il
fallait changer ses tours en gardant les
tours c'était trop dangereux
là avec le cavalier elle que la tour
connectés trop bien il y avait trop de
menaces sur ce pion ces deux
retour à 5 tours cet ordre de 5 3 6 et
le foin dans 8 après il défend j'ai deux
camps même voix les noirs non mais tu as
que c'est possible de gagner cette
position avec les noirs en réalité
puisque le roi blanc il est quand même
actif et le fouillis tient la baraque
cette façon encore une fois la garde
18 secondes de porc katrina moi je sens
qu elle la tient la clc bien active avec
le roi là là à mon avis elle la tient
j'aime bien c'etait deja six fours g8
mais bon 1 pour tout prendre un peu
comme quelqu'un est de gagner cette
[Musique]
série les blancs ne sommes pas venus ici
parce que je suis en train de me
demander
parce que si je suis peut-être pas roi
prend mais plutôt roi f6 tu vois ça tu
as changé à joué-lès-tours qui
disparaissent c'est ce qu'on a pensé
depuis le début c'est très dangereux
pour les noirs du coup oui c'était en
avons tombé f3 ok c'est bien joué je
pense de la barbarie cas de de jouer cet
échange mais c'est clairement que les
blancs qui peuvent gagner ça doit être
gagnant et c est le fouet de voir que la
couleur c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est dit
est-ce qu'on va arriver à gagner
accès par exemple les noirs sacrifient
leur colère contre le vih et le fouet de
gomme cola pour gagner celle ci oui
c'est la couleur du four mais en fait
c'est même pas sûr que tu arrives à
sacrifier le cavalier oui mais c'est
pour ça que oreca et les rives avec son
roi en étroit pour stabiliser le cavaly
en f3 oui ok attaqué le pion très bien
joué donc maintenant roi que le h4
j'arrive plus à jouer au raja trois
passes kerouac 4 oui je pense que la
place en gros de la foule ces six
cavaliers qui se prend une focale le
pion qui avance vrai c'est complètement
terminé la partie a tourné
oui ça peut être un tournant du match
elle va mettre le rond h 4 je pensais
attention le dernier piège
non il y avait la jeunesse et ce qui est
curieux kamke arica elle a perdu une
position très technique
je sais que oui c'est pas du tout un
carreau tactique
elle a perdu une finale très technique
avec un point de plus ouais mais là elle
apparaît l'a pas bien jugé
l'activité du roi blanc elle a proposé
les échanges de tours plusieurs fois
auparavant qui ont été refusées et
finalement elle n'a pas compris enfin
elle a pas compris elle a pas l a pas
fait la mise à jour dans son esprit de
la position qu avec l'orangé 5 c'était
si dangereux que ça quoi c'était une
très jolie déroger 5 quelques fois
j'évite donc resté sept projets et là
encore une ouverture que je connais très
bien la reka elle finalement joué des
quatre oui le 4 cavaliers
peu avant un million de structures
possibles dessin qui transpose dans
l'assiette mais qu il a le coup
qu'avaient les baies 3 que je connais
pas très bien parce que voilà ça offre
au noir de en fait dans la cécilienne si
on donne la possibilité de jeu des cinq
on doit la saisir
donc je dis que quand irina elle a très
bien joué je sais mais c'est la même
structure qu'auparavant et c'est marrant
parce que tu nous disais tout à l'heure
qu'il y avait des différences avec le
pion le g3 fouet deux cas on va les voir
dans cette partie
remy et et télécharger les photos de
suite aussi c'est curieux je n'aurais
pas joué ou b 4 je sais pas du tout ce
qui se passe dans cette position là ou
alors cavaliers des cinq sur la prise de
catch on laisse la population ça donne
quoi la ccxr d'être encore une meilleure
version par rapport à tout à l'heure
pour les noirs quand même parce que du
coup il ya plus le socle en e3 pour le
fou tu as tout à fait raison et mathieu
la démarche aux fauves 4 c'est ce qu'a
fait eric haïk avec des caf dans cette
position là ce que je voulais expliquer
ce que l'on peut laisser ce soin des
trois donc on veut jouer plus avec les
deux caves et les prenant 2,3 avec lada
et de jouer contre ces faux échanger un
cavalier soin de garder les deux
cavaliers omd 4 et 3 oui c'est un truc
qui peut paraître contre-intuitif au
début quand tu l'a jamais vu mais après
une fois que tu as vu quelques parties
modèle ça paraîtrait logique après les
blancs ils ont un petit problème à
mettre fin un petit problème
ils ont les deux cavaliers qui sont un
peu attachés l'un à l'autre avec ce
cavalier b3 qui aimerait bien être en f3
oui oui dans l'absolu pâte en f3 échangé
contre à votre cas mais les voilà ce que
je veux c'est avoir un cavalier en d4
cet échange ait eu 2 par exemple ce
quartier j'ai une position la fesfut b 5
ab à oui mais ça s'est super bien joué
de la part d'arica d'avoir joué d'avoir
échangé des fous pour abeda pays si et
le cavalier enfermé regarde aussi oui
c'est 3 c'est une menace absolument non
c'est super bien joué là le fou bessin
qui est vraiment un coup très fort mais
à leur fougue et cinq caisses que
j'étais forcé de prendre bas sur messi
fouda et 5 passes et c'est que c'est
qu'il y avait problème je n'aimais pas
le coup à cinq ans comme un choix parce
que sa faiblesse est caisse b5 tu as
encore une fois dans les structures là
on pose
oui à six baisses étaient peut-être plus
flexible j'essaie de garder le plan est
fier c'est de contrôler les caisses b5
et mais en fait il est même difficile de
trouver enfin faut vraiment
bien chercher parce que tu peux juste
perdre une pièce sur le champ et perdre
la partie immédiatement là avec les
noirs moi j'étais en train de calculer à
4 ans elle est ce que je suis obligé de
prendre un bain 4bet shove position il
est pas très joyeuse mais je peux
peut-être sur l'a 4 juin jusqu'à va
laisser cinq peut-être je cite souhait
de partir avec le cavalier la mélasse
7,3 presque est à même de me prend b4
après oui ça pas été joués mesure c'est
terrible je sais pas si un coût pour les
noirs mais qu'est ce qu'elle dit
l'ordinateur l'ordinateur d'un mètre
carré atteint 9,4 ah oui je comprends
donc pour affaiblir les caisses des
trois cc oui c'est un coup oui
intéressant et une belle défense et
changer les dames et je vais sur ces
trois jeunes et des trois maisons mais
on va toujours perdre et le plein à
saint lô qu'est ce qui se passe et on
peut prendre un instant que c'est celle
appartient j'ai trouvé qu'elle avait
monde carrick a joué très vite dame
point f4 normalement c'est quand même le
genre de situation où tu prends un peu
de temps tu dire que c'était une
position ont créé un quartier c'est
peut-être le meilleur cours d'un bref 4
mais tu peux prendre 30 secondes en 5 +
1 oui mais même temps et c'est une suite
qui est tellement naturelle tu prends un
but 4 tu prends à la synthèse casillas
maintenant puisque c'est en gagnant que
ça au final ces gros avantage mais c'est
peut-être pas si simple à gagner ça
n'oubliez pas que tu te reste toujours
ce point isolé
à mon avis est là elle réfléchit en
termes de
des structures aussi je transpose dans
cette finale a donc elle transforme son
avantage et s'est dit déjà que oui je
sais ce qui se passe mais c'est je
comprends ce que tu veux dire c'est que
elle considère que c'est techniquement
gagnant et qu'elle va réussir à le faire
si elle a le temps et encore une fois ce
serait peut-être beaucoup plus simple à
jouer où les coups peuvent étancher
newtest donc là là elle réfléchit elle a
toujours un avantage ton tour d un
probablement pour 1,5 non qu'est ce que
tu penses
non je dis à tous je vous laisse je vais
tour a des seins comme ça tu le sais qu
est ce que je peux gagner le plus
directement mais tour des 5 9 4 6 1
j'aime bien mais attend il n'y a pas
tout reprend équivalent epr f ou même
cavaliers pros f4 dirais mais après j'ai
pas quelque chose qu'on ne sait cette
es11 session en scannant qu'elle allait
des 6 et 7
voilà tu prends un art si tu prends et
tu prends en cavale et 4 mais on va
faire ça mais j'ai compris ce que tu
faisais bien que 17,7 depuis comprenez
tu as besoin du cavalier en et cissé
mais contrôler la casse et 7 très bien
jouer qu'après leur est léger c'est ceci
est qu'est-ce qui a été jouée rice prisa
et tour ses huit c'est l'écho mais j'ai
l'impression qu'elle récupère ses 6 nos
cavaliers à c'est peut-être un peu
maladroit jouer mais bon touriste aura
huit noms lagarde fera vite elle aurait
pu faire 3 8 bat nantes aura 3 alors
c'est tout s'est tu
mais bon elle menace qui est pro f4
maintenant est sûre j'ai trois cavaliers
des carabines leurs atouts et les
cavaliers c'est vrai il est très mal
placée ce que dès qu'il fait cai bessin
qui a tout reprend et à jamais tour à 6
tours b 6 puisque ya le cavalier qui
emprise est ce que j'étais et je peux
même pas jouer tout raciste en baisse
parce que l'on craignait tant prisée
tourné sept tours à vie tout simplement
ok parce que qu'elle ait des quatre on
commence qu'il ne compte protéger ce
pion cissé prend elle le laisse elle
doit vouloir jouer peut-être pour
agencer qu'elle voulait cavale et b5 et
jouer pour quelque chose mais elle a
peut-être juste décidé que il fallait
pas trop traîner dans cette partie 1 à 3
c est encore tout recettes avec les
dettes de jouer héros f2 3,3 et héros
des cadeaux des quatre donc très bien
joué de la part de katrina et là encore
une fois on voit que tout a changé
que pourrais je pense que les blancs
sont symboliquement lieux n'ont même pas
symboliquement je veux dire ils s'en
sortent même maintenant couple a encore
quelques cours et le rapt la neige quoi
alors attends s qui règne à temps il
reste 36 secondes ça veut dire que si la
partie termine maintenant il y aura
encore une partie en cinq puisse ainsi
elle joue encore 30 secondes à partir
d'ici
c'en sera terminée de cette cadence donc
ça l'a vu que ça a joué un petit peu
c'est la dernière partie en 5 + 1 et ça
va probablement non probablement ce kit
est à égalité je vais jeter un oeil à
leur classement en bullet 2006 anciens
63 pour arica et 2632 ah oui donc elles
elles sont proches dans tout les
cadences et laissait quand elle essaie
de trouver quelques chances 5 à 3 des 5
quoi s'ajoute une foufoune el mandeb
même en longueur j'ai envie de te dire
oui donc si je peux être plus simple de
tenir parce que tu vas tu es quelqu'un
et 1,5 sur tourbe et ses trois filles
est donc tu vois tu es obligé de prendre
un hcc
mais là ça va fermer automatiquement ont
ils vont avec et teleco ouais ça je
pensais qu'elle allait faire re 5 tours
de roi des cinq ex allait répéter comme
ça attention quand même ne pas la perdre
un pur arica gens qui te dire tu
commences à jouer pour dessein que tu te
prends un échec le point f part ça peut
être dangereux
non mais là non ça va
j'aurais jamais fait tout reprendre là
on va donc les joueuses envoyer les
anciens 15 en cinq minutes de pause oui
c'est exact ça à faire 10 c'est nul je
crois dans tous les cas de figure non
non évidemment cela ça saigne et
j'essaie juste de comprendre s'il ya une
petite chance tu essaies de jouer pour
ses cinq tours des 5 janvier et est en
train de voir exactement le même piège
c'est vrai this is it en train de me
dire wife cinq tours ces cinq études il
ya 3-4 et donc ça ça marche pas non plus
le petit piège classique
bon il fait toujours plaisir à celui là
alors faire tout re 1 8 je pense f3 d
imiter le roi va venir e4 et c'est nul
c'est la position
les dead
dupont qu'on essayait de trouver ça va
de moins en marché parce que le pion va
avancer
il va quand même falloir avec les blancs
ont donné à les faire dame
oui toujours la c6r f4 quelques os 4
elle insiste oui mais je reviendrai des
6es tour des six 6 mois donc c'était le
dernier piège dans cette position là on
pouvait y aura t il quatre images fini
ce match à présent c'est ça non égalité
égalité devant une vue 3d complètement
aveugle et où le score ah non il écrit
en tout petit à côté des noms donc il
est vrai un client petit ans pour les
spectateurs il est que mon plus grand à
côté des capitaux mais pour nous il est
petit et ben écoute match très serré
franchement après après cette première
ce premier tiers temps c'est difficile
de donner une favorite en réalité en
pense et katia un petit peu au dessus en
début de match mais là c'est vraiment du
50 50
oui c'est vrai est-ce que sur ce point
quand il y en a aussi les uns les lots 1
1 3 ou pas du tout c'est le même et
l'aube 5 + 1 et ils ont exactement le
même classement en 2007 sens 2716 et en
bullet et à 30 points d'écart c'est la
même chose en fait
elles ont exactement les mêmes
classement et je crois qu'elles ont le
même niveau
c'est une discipline tellement de
déchets ciel j'ai tu vois quand l union
soviétique encore une fois quand
quand le ciel est cours d'échecs ce
genre de l'exercice nous était interdit
oui et tu vois à quel point la belle
époque il est différente puisque les
jeux d'échecs devient de plus en plus tu
sais fait partie de je dirais de cette
société de spectacles qui est très
curieux donc on essaie de nous divertir
de plus en plus avec l'image de plus en
plus spectaculaires mais je n'arrive
même pas ce que tu vois parfois ça va
tellement vite
bon je vois de plus en plus mal mais je
ne vois même pas le coût mais moi je
suis pas je suis pas fan un perso dû
personnellement du bullet je trouve que
ça va trop vite on voit vraiment rien et
je sais pas si évidente de commenter
pour ce que j'essaie de trouver le fil
conducteur il appartient ce terme n ya
pas y'a pas de fil conducteur j'ai envie
de te dire ça clique au hasard sa clique
sa clique 1 le bullet que c'est c'est eh
bien quelqu'un qui demande dans le chatt
tiens je me permets de te poser la
question aussi ça et je me demandais
pourquoi tu jouais pas le top 12 cette
année c'est un choix ou en fait c'est
parce que je n'ai pas d'équipé toque de
c'est très simple j'ai jeu seulement un
top 10 féminin où sera peut-être un top
10 je ne sais pas cette année là pour
l'équipe de monaco et cette année je
n'avais pas du tout l'équipe avec monaco
du coup oui on va jouer le championnat
de france féminin est probablement la
coupe d'europe
tu te concentres sur ces compétitions là
plutôt que
pas du tout a choisi un club pour jouer
ces compétitions là mais qui fout pas le
top-12 quoi c'est un choix sportif
c'est un choix sportif mais en même
temps tu te souviens l'année dernière on
a évoqué c'est la situation qui a été
créée d'avoir l'époque d'amis où toutes
les professions étaient dans une
situation c'est cédric mer et donc il y
avait pas trop de tournois donc à ce
moment là il n'y avait plus de tournois
donc on voulait jouer quelques c'est qui
quelques tournois par équipe avec monaco
et il se concentrer plutôt sur les
terrains féminin est il cette année là
j'ai je vais aussi jouer la coupe du
monde voilà ça commence dans dix jours
jours billets déjà ce que c'était
d'ailleurs il me semble que vous avez
commenté sur la chaîne notre match avec
des montées en quad
on a joué un match à shah alors
aujourd'hui non j'en ai parlé avec des
montées mais je n'ai pas vu on dirait
qu'il n'y paraît j'en ai pas parlé que
des montées dont j'ai parlé avec mathieu
d'accord parce que c'était un match
tellement difficile se faisait un an et
demi qu'on a roulé en tout cas moi
augmenter le verdit plus d'expérience
que je n'ai pas touché les pièces valent
à même d'avoir cette sensation physique
de pêcher de toucher les pièces étaient
extrêmement étrange donc je suis très
contente de voir jouer ces quatre
portiers d'abord que je veux c'est
quatre parties les coupes du monde et
par le plus grand des hasards tu sais si
on pas si on passe toutes les deux le
premier tour je vais rencontrer marie
sebag au deuxième tour un deuxième tour
est là ça ça va être un berbère est
français un genou contre lui au premier
tour
je joue contre une jeune joueuse
d'égyptiennes j'ai regardé la jouer sur
les couleurs de l'équipe nationale au
championnat du monde par équipes
c'est une joueuse qui se qualifie ma
chatte fois pour les voies pour les
tournois officiels dont le coût de 5 et
4 de chaque parti aujourd'hui je change
les cavaliers
c'est pas si évident on va l'être
d'entamer la préparation après un après
cette parenthèse qui a duré très
longtemps
et du coup tu as tu un objet que tu as
envie de gagner ou quoi ou tout simple
objectif c'est juste d'aller t'amuser
jouer un petit peu aux échecs ou d'un
objectif tu dis j'ai envie d'aller
jusqu'en finale ou même gagné la
compétition
si c'était il ya une dizaine d'années
oui j'aurais j'aurais eu des objectifs
complètement différent là je suis
tellement heureuse de participer à la
complimente d'ailleurs j'espère que le
tournoi sera organisé pour les
situations tellement léger qu'en russie
n'êtes pas si les dents tu avais pas
pensé il ya peut-être des questions qui
commencent à se poser ou c'est pour le
moment on vend on a le feu vert mais
j'attends moins bizarre mais encore une
fois j'ai regardé mes statistiques tu
sais danser tourne à la avant c'était le
championnat du monde maintenant c'est la
première d'ailleurs je suis éliminé au
premier tour bon j'espère que ce sera
pas le cas soit je vais un peu plus loin
vers l'écart final avec c'est un tournoi
qui est complètement différent cette
fois parce qu'il ya plus de jeu et ce
qu'ils jouent les fédérations
internationales a offert heures et créer
cette possibilité pour les joueuses
d'intégrer pour les meilleures joueuses
du monde d'intégrer le tournoi au 2e
tour oui c'est bien c'est bien qu'ils
imposent
je trouve que c'est une très bonne
initiative d'avoir fait ça évidemment et
autant que pour le tournage imminent
pour le tourner à mx et on se sera une
vraie fête chez tienne je n'ai plus du
tout l'habitude si c'était l'impression
tu vas voir tellement de joueurs dans un
endroit en même temps quand j'ai
commencé le tournoi des candidats les
trois premiers jours ont été un peu
parsemer par les sensations de stress
post traumatique j'étais plus sûrs et ce
que j'en enlève le masque gens lèvent
pas le masque
quelle joie de voir les sourires et de
voir les tournois du coup ça moscou 7
chez assa sotchi donc ça peut aller
ça peut passer oui la ville mais en même
temps ceux çi au mois de juillet tu vois
c'est le saint tropez russe oui je
connais j'y suis allée c je connais tu
sais pas oui non et je veux dire c'est
une des bas pour la chaîne j'étais
subjugué presse que tu sais pas quand je
parlais avec mathieu il m'a dit que tu
es vous avez pendant les tournages de
candidats à nombre de 2 comment est
votre communauté extraordinaire je sais
pas quel était le but on a eu trente
cinq mille personnes en pic
oui mais on ne suit on était on était
derrière maxime à fond les gens les gens
suivaient plus maxime entre guillemets
que enfin oui nous suivait aussi bien
sûr mais il suivait aussi les exploits
de maxime c'est on n'a jamais vu un
joueur français kiki qui performent
comme ça évidemment c'était probablement
la première chance je ne sais pas
comment ça dépend si on considère ce
qu'est ce qui vous allez qui n'en fait
comme français oui mais c'était
naturalisé bien plus tard donc tu vois
c'est
et encore une fois les poké story qui
était complètement différente
le contexte historique a donc qu'est-ce
qu'on a on allie keane una liqin ça peut
être un choix surprenant mais tu sais
que c'est fin c'est une ouverture qui
est pas si les alains qui est très à la
mode ces derniers temps parce que passer
c'est un peu encore une fois de il faut
en fait sa force les blancs de jouer une
suite de coups très concrète à chaque
fois ici jamais tu la joues pas tu
choisis pas le vin est la plus concrète
pour la plus offensive en l'occurrence
c'est après tirrena la joue et c'est
dans cette position là les noirs on se
rendront pas de problème dans
l'ouverture et même un peuvent espérer
oui peut pas espérer avoir une position
et j'ai remarqué il sait démente et qui
joue un peu ça j'ai vu jouer plusieurs
fois l'hallali qui n'a elle s'en sort
toujours très bien dans l'ouverture il
alain vite te dire tu vas c'est une des
céline qu'il faut connaître par coeur
comme en anglais en fait je ne sais plus
quel angle ya quelques jours j'ai
commandé un anglais donc je voulais dire
à notre vraie famille avec dom la 4g pas
tu n'es pas très au courant des courants
a encore une fois des derniers d'un par
la théorie en tout cas ça paraît
dangereux pour les noirs mais après ça
doit être théorique et ça doit tenir
mais visuellement c'est dangereux pour
les deux membres et tu vas la faiblesse
des cases noires a peut être exploité
tout de suite comme en fait foi g7
j'aurais très peur mais peut-être sais
rien roger c'est toi g7 dans la crise
tout simplement rajouter à ça et car
elle est 17 pour la suite jusqu'à ce que
j'aime bien comme quoi je trouve que
c'est fort comme coup h-47f oui pour le
blé de surtout et ans
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire non cash
jusqu'à 35
alors est-ce qu'on peut prendre en des
cas ce que j'allais dire pour ramener la
dame en f5 en défense
et là je me suis posé la question tu
sais est-ce qu'on peut tout sacrifier
ici peut-être pas on ne peut pas jouer
g4 reprendra tous les faire j'ai quatre
laissez abbaoui mais regarder jouer
assez léger 4 un coureur mais c'est dans
l'esprit de la position de ces je me
suis dit quitte à sacrifier l'aide de
pions pourquoi rugby en plus ça donne un
coup de développement qui va donner
grand rendez après exactement c'est ce
que j'ai envisagé un visage et qu'elle
les prend ces trois écrans mais encore
une fois qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
cavaler décès puis vers la défense s'est
peut-être jouée à la clé des bruits oui
de bouger la tour est joué que cavaye
chut faut pas oublier aussi ici que
c'est plus du 5 puis ça c'est du 3 + 1
donc c'est encore plus dangereux en ce
genre d' attaque mais ce qui explique le
choix de katrina et donc qu'est-ce qu'on
peut jouer c'est sûr qu'ils valident des
sages est à dire qu il ya 17 mai dame
prend des quatre du coup c'est quoi le
matériel après brel pu échanger les
dames attention attention qui vient d'en
prendre le cap damouzy 5 et oui bien vu
adam s'est terminée à dos bien joué 7 5
encore quelques commentaires sur sûreté
chez eux kevin je crois que je vais te
surpasser jeu à chaque gare je vais sur
sa paix sur la chaise
voilà tu as lattes as je t'avais dit que
je serai tranquille aujourd'hui parce
qu'il ya en fait moi j'ai joué un
tournoi
oui
et j'ai très bien joué du coup je suis
allé très loin dans le bracket
et quand je suis un petit peu fatigué
mais ce terme est net retrait tard
l'adresse c'était un mineta et puis en
plus du coup j'ai pas bien dormi parce
que j'ai battu sadoine y est meilleure
2-0 tu vois et après on card je sais pas
quel meilleur c'est georges guillaume
meyer a gagné et ça doit ni c'est un
petit bain jeune mais qui est beaucoup
trop
cette manière-là c'était pas le genre
que ce que les chais pour le tour moi ou
pas du tout mon jeu mais dangereux il
s'est enfui en suisse est qualifiée pour
pas mal de choses je sais pas de quel
tournoi tu parles récemment pour le
tournage mag ne surent pas jeetoo cette
magnifique du cash qui s'est qualifiée
mais ça doit ni les pas moins forcée à
peu près du même du même acabit
ouais je voulais te dire que c'était pas
fini mais j'aimais bien ce coup d'un 24
dans le cadre que mieux ça qu'elle
centralise le cavalier menace qu'un
élève 3 qu'est ce que je peux faire
chier jouer pour g35 elle veut jouer sur
quel élève trois dames et 6es avec les
deux pieds sur collégiens mais il n'y a
pas de suisse à côté ça doit jamais
marché déjà au pire il ya peut-être eu
des mains d'un machin et e5 déjà oui
avec d'un projet cadre d'un escadron va
pas rendre le tout est marrante mais tu
échanges les dames déjà rien que ça mais
bon après 27 secondes
ça fait peur mais là il se met trop bas
l'otan attention qu'elle élève 3 9 6 mai
c'est à dire qu'il a calculé la suite
ouais calculé ça aider à calculer à
l'accueil d'un machin si je joue
cavalier des deux je sacrifie le reste
après après damas charest je vais cavale
et d'aider sacrifier les pour lcl c'est
foutu mal autant f3 aller j'annonce une
victoire des blancs j'annonce victoire
des blancs parce qu'elle est en train de
faire n'importe quoi sur 5 ya pions
prend maintenant avec dame pranger six
dames f6 c'est hyper dangereux
c'est un coin elle s'est inventé une vie
elle s'inventer une vie à arica je pense
un petit damev six échecs cavaliers des
deux personnes mais bon oui j'ai pensé
je me suis dit mais est-ce que j'ai le
temps de ramener la dame après je vais
d'un match 7
en fait matériel monte plus si derrière
que ça quoi non mais c'est une super
position pour les abysses à ces dames
distingue dans le projet 4 non mais
attends que pas maté battante damas si
c'est pour julien dont jouit encore plus
haut c'est terrible mais arrive c'est
incroyable elle a elle a paniqué en fait
oui mais je la comprends très bien en
fait c'est pas si simple de jeu ses
positions avec quelques secondes à la
part dieu
il est à des ménages de ma très
concrètes peut-être je sais pas ce qu'il
disait l'ordinateur peut-être qu elle
évoluer sa position à moins de 10 mais a
parfois il ya une scène de suite une
seule suite de coups qui gagne mais tu
sais je pense dans ce genre de positions
surtout en blitz il faut vraiment
réussir à rester calmes et à calculer
genre tu y as essayé de calculer une
ligne en force et et pas commencer à
avoir trop émotif et souvent quand on
est mal autant et moi le premier un tu
commence à paniquer tu commences à
calculer deux trois variantes en même
temps j'ai pas su à ce que je veux dire
c'est 7 kg exactement mais ça veut dire
en fait je saute d'une variante et
l'autre parce que tu n'arrives pas à
faire marcher la première variante tu
commencé la deuxième
parfois la troisième après tu aurais
bien l'avouer la première oui oui ça
m'arrive très souvent dans sa c4 quand
ça quand tu commences à faire ça c'est
catastrophique
il tua il rejoue exactement on a dû et
le tueur est qu'aujourd'hui quelque part
il revient à la sicilienne avec avel f3
chez 3 une autre structure avec un club
très intéressant à troyes b 4 fautes
bêtes de wes assez fort un le fou sur la
grande diagonale dans ces structures là
il est monstrueux
en même temps tu vois elle réussit à
jouer fouet 5 fouilles 4 j'aime beaucoup
cette idée là ont des changes et les
fous de tout simplement de le garder
pour le moment mais attention à la case
of 5
est ce que j'allais dire après ta cabane
et f5 qui tapait si la dame arrive au g4
c'est quasiment matra par contre elle
lui a forcé faire forcer à la provoc et
c3 c3 c3 j'aime pas mais bon en anglais
je sais pas si c'était fort c est ce
qu'il ya une autre possibilité
je sais pas mais j'ai l'impression que l
est sous le choc aux fêtes haricots et
tu vois ce genre de coup c'est 3 c'est
une indication qui dit en tout cas pour
le joueur en face j'essaie juste de ne
pas gâcher
oui elle essaie de consolider sa
position où toutes les pièces soient
protégés et 1 c'est une claire
indication que pour le moment ils
essaient juste de reprendre ses esprits
allez jouer jouer des coups et devrait
jouer une partie comme le dirait murtagh
venaient jouer une partie joué des coups
très sain il sait très bien que
peut-être lassé son côté fait elle n'a
pas du tout les positions chaotique ces
mêmes qui ont un côté dans une approche
complètement irrationnel je ne gère pas
très bien le carreau et
on a vu que ça lui est complètement
échappé et là tu as le rejoue les mêmes
coûts h trois rois goethe a vraiment
l'impression comme tu le disais qu'elle
voulait elle joue pas vraiment la
position en soi et jouent juste les
coûts qui lui paraissent plus ou moins
logiques lie alors dit qu'ils montrent
un truc joli mais qu'ils étaient trop
vagues pour f1 foulée 5 à fin fond des
sacs oui un très joli mais je n'aime pas
du tout le coup à 4,6 et f3 f3 je trouve
ça horrible aux siens d'y vivre comme ça
la deuxième commande mais je pense que
mathieu dirais que c'est moche c'était
après il peut dire c'est pas si cons oui
mais les regarde le plancher 3 non merci
c'est vraiment moche pas tant le foie
jeudi que le plancher 3 et katyal essaie
de ne pas faire jouer avec kafka toute
façon et de l'attaqué immédiatement donc
comment on peut protéger quatre coups
peut-être je te fous je sais pas s'il
faut aucun tous cavaliers f6 mais
peut-être fou 4 d'avoir pu éviter les
prévenus sont possibles et tu vois
qu'elle allait acheter actu a provoqué
quatre cavaliers 6 tu tu aurais bien
tout simplement les deux une proposition
bien g5 aussi qui peut partir à tout
moment
j'ai cinq mais attention mais qu'avaient
les fils est ce maintenant on est forcé
et un bal et blanc vont devoir jouer ces
quatre aussi un moment je sais il faut
absolument oblige à presque des coups
comme dame b 5 tu vois ouais faut
calculer d'un dessin que j'ai je
changerai pas je ne pas y changer la
donne c'est ce que j'ai trouvé tout de
suite dans ce sens là en fait dans cette
position-là jeu
j'aurais gardé les dames parce qu'avec
les des deux quitte à sacrifier même 1 à
4 j'aurais pris un jeu de ea jouer dans
trois mois je regardais les dames après
deux dames b5 j'aurais joué damas est du
coup tu t'en fiches ouais tu joues pour
lattes pour le oui pour line cette
initiative qui ont mangé g33 f4 l'a1 à
curan je pense pas que tu aurais pu tout
protéger j'aurais pris 1,8 j'aurais
monter le roi a donc tu prends damas
huit airways 3
je me serais dit que j'aurais 5 puisque
tu as du cavalier c3 qui est prompt à 4
je me serais dit qu'en fait ces trois
pions la c1
il n'y a pas de monde où les noirs les
gardes les trois je veux dire que tu vas
en récupérer un quand même et je jouais
cavell et b5 avaler que ces trois quatre
ou alors elle veut garder le cavalier en
bessin qui est un peu approché
thual peut aussi faire croire f3 et sur
qui a aidé cissé changé et continue à
monter mais j'aime bien le coup m6
d'ailleurs de garder le faut il y a
essayé de faire valoir notre pion de
passer ce qui arrive six cavaliers 401
louis précise qu est-ce que c'est parce
que 2004 je protège je prends la laisse
en fait impliqué quand même 1 par
rapport à la partie précédente elle a
réussi à jouer vite
est-ce que je peux jouer ici c'est 3 et
après cavaliers des six cavaliers c4 web
elle le joue bien mais c'est encore une
fois ce sont les cookies sont très
naturels
voilà je coupe un peu un quinqua excès
surtout et la casse 3 g tech le pion en
a trois et qu'ils veulent et b2 se
prennent et donc reculé à 4 je pense
qu'elle a calculé cette suite mais c'est
pas clair y'a peut-être qui a réalisé
cinq mamans 6,5 et 5,0 des trois c'est
hyper compliqué là
voilà comment on se dirige vers une pio
nal de pions quitté galles va peut-être
cavaliers b2 cavaliers bessette avec cdc
qui est très linéaire et si donc c'est
assez simple et aurait pas été un tout
petit peu inquiète avec les noirs avec
lui ses gonds louis là je viens de me
rendre compte que les noix raison mais
encore une fois tu vas tu calcules et en
ligne s'ils tapent à 3 de choix ouais
les séries que le roi même si tu fais
c'est un cap sista plus de quinze
d'entre eux par contre les fils j'ai pas
trop aimé avec du froid c'est ça trois
des cinq rois 17 nope médiation way et
tu vas réussir à faire annuler comme ça
c'est bien joué de la part de katia mais
c'était pas loin de perdre
well as ta rien avec les blancs mais une
parfaite démonstration en cours de de la
technique en finale qui je trouve une
élève de les deux joueuses ont très bien
joué donc je n'ai pas mais tu vois que
le changement de stratégie de la part de
l'erika pour les 3 1 elle a préparé les
liquides moi j'aime bien et si je
vérifie ses quatre faux b3 je vois dans
la proche du match là ça ressemble
vraiment beaucoup au match de speechless
mixte avec des ouvertures choisi pour
pour tout les cadences il ya personne
qui se fait trouer sur une ouverture et
c'est par rapport au premier tour où tu
sentais qu'il y avait des joueuses qui
étaient quand même clairement plus forte
et donc des matchs qui est un petit peu
décousu là je trouve que les joueuses
elles sont vraiment venu avec des idées
très claires et est très bien préparée
tu vois elle a changé caterina parce que
je suis maman que tu expliquer la
différence jeu j'étais en train de me
demander est ce qu'elle est amélioré sa
variante là et si tu te souviens dans
l'autre partie les noirs aux rockets oui
donc après foulée 6 oui donc là elle
choisit qu'avaient les f60 clairoix
mais encore une fois ces positions là ne
sont pas faciles
mais comme ça au premier abord on peut
se dire voilà le roi et de rock et il ya
les cases noires sont faibles mais les
noirs ont beaucoup de beaucoup à leur
disposition la fasch 4 elle va se
reprendre reprend des quatre j'ai
l'impression qu'elle elle se perd
peut-être un petit peu katia dans cette
ouverture parce que arica elle avait
déjà l'air dans la première de très bien
connaître
elle a l'air d'avoir juste très bien
étudié cette variante est qu'un tiens ça
sent qu'elle bloque quoi qu'elle qu'elle
sait pas en fait qu'elles se rappellent
pas ou qu'elle a même jamais su
précisément match on a regardé auch et
les positions mais c'était une là avec
mathieu dans l'allée qui regarde elle
perd une pièce déjà désolé de te couper
oui oui oui à y perdre déjà une place
aux mondiaux payer et encore tu vois ce
qui compliquait avec ses positions là
c'est qu'il faut les analyser très
longtemps et l'ordinateur change très
souvent d'avis oui oui c'est juste pour
expliquer au fait pourquoi les joueuses
sam verslegers coûte dans des lignes là
lorsque c'est pas si évident au premier
abord je dis ça à l'air très joli mais
c'est une légende c'est que tu peux tout
de suite perdre mais insiste d'ailleurs
le prouve un commentaire et si je prends
un jet keskes pas se fier et je pense
qu'il se passe je pense qu'il se passe
rien été ce qui est marrant c'est que ça
se voit que c'est arica qui est beaucoup
mieux préparé pour jouer des positions
mais on sent aussi qu'elle n'est pas
vraiment à l'aise mais mais bon elle est
complètement gagnant du plan sahel va
les gagner mais c'est marrant parce que
je prends g5 tout simplement pas sans
sacrifices de pièces positionnait leon
joe cette aura chante au rachat d'un
match 3g point f et un jour et le point
je sais tu
oui oui on sait il faut il faut terminer
c'est vrai comme henri callat l'air d'un
petit peu paniqué où se poser trop de
questions s'est pas fait encore mais
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire concrètement
est ce tu vois comment comment je me
développe donc j'essaie de le problème
de ce projet cette a5 a10 propose cinq à
deux mois 5 à 4 oui c'est un progrès
après au pire on peut faire cavalier
dessin qu'on peut se payer le luxe après
donner un pion quoi derrière le fait
direct parce que je voulais quand même
tenté un échec perpétuelle qu'avait
lâche sept kayakistes série me disait si
tu veux pas prendre un mot pire jaros
atteint quand même pas de chance
pratique au fait ya eu des cinq je pense
c'est un coup c'est un bon coup humain
ça en fait je veux juste prendre un f6
et 6 i way et les blancs ils peuvent
récupérer un pion mais ils sont ils ont
quoi ils ont une pièce net de retard et
en plus ils ont une structure pourri
mais c'est une grosse question que
comment katia va jouer dans la prochaine
partie avec les blancs parce que si tu
rejoues là les kin ça fait deux fois que
les noirs sont complètement gagnant est
le problème c'est que t'as pas le temps
d'allumer leur dit c'est souvent
j'observe les grands joueurs même
pendant les grandes chez stora pu
doubler saison ces deux trois minutes
ceux où il ya même une seconde en qui
les attendent
adam est là dans les selles qui peach
pit les joueurs qui sortent dans la
formule 1 tu changes en hausse et une
voiture toute neuve donc c'est un jour
tout neuf qui ressort de licite t'as pas
le temps on est ravi de vérifier la
variante moi je trouve que c'est bien
que tu ai pas le temps justement ce que
ce qui explique que quatre salles sais
pas et ça ça c'est bien ça redonne un
peu le côté humain moi je suis assez
frustré quand je suis des échecs ou même
quand je joue que les préparations
maintenant elle soit si longue
je suis d'accord avec toi tu sais je me
suis rendu compte que
même le tournoi des candidats à
commencer par cette partie absolument
magnifique malheureusement que maxime a
perdu montre fabiano oui contre effet
bien nommé qui a montré aussi la
profondeur de la préparation des deux
joueurs surtout les capacités de maxime
à prendre les meilleures décisions mais
face à une telle proposition préparation
tu vois il a tellement bien joué cette
partie il même les coups qu'il a un
visage et les profondeurs de ses calculs
j'étais absolument bouleversés même pas
plus tard tu fais comme telles a
expliqué sa dent dans l'analyse et ça
c'est exceptionnel
le niveau de jeu de maxime dans cette
partie d'ailleurs c'est une partie qui à
mon avis aurait été tellement
déterminante pour la suite du tournoi
pour pour maxime oui mais en même temps
voilà ce que je voulais dire j'étais un
tellement affectée par ce fait le que
maintenant avec le ballet programme pour
fêter chez ken qui sont devenus de plus
en plus forte voilà ce type de
préparation même si jusqu'à 40e coup
soit possible oui oui mais c'est nous on
est souvent me sens frustré mais que
quelque part c'est dimension créative
n'intervient pas plus tôt et c'est
frustrant quand et spectateurs pour moi
c'est frustrant quand tu es joueur aussi
je trouve que c'est ça a dépassé un peu
le cadre qui aurait dû rester mais mais
ya pas de solution a malheureusement tu
peux rien faire contre c'est comme ça
oui mais martin je suis dit je t'aime
j'aime beaucoup lire les articles
je me suis dit que peut-être la seule la
singularité de cette technologique c'est
pas pour demain
lorsque l'ordinateur l'ordinateur les
chambres d'application d'application
sont tellement différent mais je me dis
que l'ordinateur ne possède pas encore
si je pense qu'ils se distinguent
l'intelligence artificielle de
raisonnement et moi c'est
l'esprit critique weening et on le voit
seront quand même ordinateur était guidé
par l'être humain et donc je dis
peut-être qu'on a encore un peu de temps
oui je dirais qu'on lui parti désormais
que votre premier 5 3006 mais je me pose
la question c'est quel est le sens à oui
non mais c'est alors parti à la plupart
du temps c'est césar alors du coup
d'essai se regarda il a joué d4rk elle a
changé un peu de stratégie que turinah
joomla grünfeld donc des cavaliers
squelette 3g si c'est pour ça qu'il a
joué cavalier b d2 oui donc ou jet set
et il a transposé plus tu vas à lire une
perte mais du côté est les jeux très
bien position là aussi tu vois c'est
vraiment marrant parce que je discutais
avec vlad et des deux premiers matchs de
katia justement d'en discuter sur la
chaîne où il disait katia avait pas
assez changé d'ouverture avec c'est en
tant que coach il n'était pas était papa
très content quoi de des choix et j'ai
vraiment l'impression dans ce match là
je reviens un peu sur ce que je disais à
la partie d'avant mais que les deux
joueuses la lll prennent elles prennent
les bonnes décisions quand ça se passe
mal elle change raisons elles sont venus
avec beaucoup d'idées c'est vraiment
intéressant quoi c'est un vrai combat
mais ce sont de très bonnes joueuses en
fait c'est le dernier a d'ailleurs je
pense que catherine a écrit rika ce sont
les deux sont favorites parmi parmi les
favorites de cette coupe du monde
et voyez un hameau du tube mais
évidemment tu sais le problème c'est que
les oeufs les joueuses chinoises ne vont
probablement pas jouer la coupe du monde
oui ils n'arrivent pas à avoir les
autorisations non les autorisations de
leurs gouvernements locaux
c'est dur très spécifique donc quand
j'ai regardé les appariements je veux
que les jeunes chinoises n'auront pas
joué donc ce qu'est ce qui offre une
occasion unique a même temps à d'autres
gestes de l'élite de la gagner il n'y a
pas de juin d'une donc la choque pas me
demande ne joue pas
et puis jouer chinoise on avait vu
d'ailleurs la passoire à la demi finale
de demain il y aura ting tings tings j'y
vois là pareil moi je l'appelle shinji
je sais pas esthétique j son nom mais je
l'appelle thing j ouer âgées les jouer
elle a l'air super sympa la caméra quand
on la voit et ce qu'elle est sympa dans
la vie ou pas elle a l'air sympa les
images que j'ai vues ce tout à la fois
ce que sa femme s'était pas d'émotions
ouais mais non oui mon bien et jouent
non et elle a l'air cool j'ai pas mangé
truc elle avait l'air cool est-ce que
j'ai ouï geste et quelques photos est
vraiment de trois secondes
j'ai eu deux occasions encore de
l'observer un peu plus bas ce sera les
présente des membres
demain le nom de black se représentera
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est une
position car oui quand tu plus pour
libérer juste à cause du point 6 mai un
vrai cette supposition égal après tu
joues un peu quand même
aprilia tiennent mais pour ces huit ours
et deux oui sauf que tous les deux très
bien on n'a pas joué
j'ai trois encore dans cette position là
il faut jouer j'ai 3 pour offrir cette
caisse de fuite en jet 2 mais oui je me
suis dit tour ces deux à quatre baies 5
tout simplement
elle vient de juger trois c'est ça c'est
logique 1 pour donner une case au roi et
la tour annoncé qu'elles iront ces deux
tu vois plus pour ceux ci attention
arica autant quand même ans puisque dans
cette position là faut pas s'endormir
il faut continuer à jouer vite faut être
là cette tendance erekat de transposer
dans les cénacles de tours et il m'a
torturé pendant sept heures dans un
grand prix dans une finale deux tours va
là où jamais une seule faiblesse
j'ai craqué dans la fange et jean
souvenir tellement horrible que cette
partie là tu vas faut être quatre sa
confiance est tendance et faudra jouer
plutôt une finale deux tours avec une
faiblesse c'est peut-être d'un prêt
notre ce que c'est là où ce deal peut
pas gaffer way
regardez-le tournicote pas mal un tour
aux trois tours f3 l onas des fous ou 5
à mon avis faire fou 5 à foisches si ça
les change comme ça c'est bien joué
du coup on va prendre tout reprend 7
mais qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et
maintenant tu vas l'euro a fait qu était
la cible et le pion angers 6-3 6-7
deuxième faiblesse que se crée pour f4
très bien joué au g7 et maintenant ils
vont peut-être monter le roi bon il
répète web elle avait plus trop de temps
elle a peut-être pas pas voulu tenter le
diable
alors ça repart dans la vie qu'il reste
18 minutes dans cette cadence et c'est
ça me demande ça me démangeait en tant
que joueuse d'échecs que je vous mais
moi j'ai pas ça j'aurais envie de le
lire mon ordi de regarder jouer
mais là n'a changé deux variantes avec
toi tu vas rien et s'élève ailleurs
d'ailleurs on va là qui est très à la
mode avec l'idée de joseph auger 4 x 2
je sais pas si après de jouer qu'un
associé des cinq élus attention c'est
pas sûr b3 direct qui a des cinq en fait
j'ai fait une vidéo avec fap sur cette
variante là donc on adule étudier et se
sait que lors de coups et hyper
important mais je me rappelle plus si cb
trois fous de foot un bébé toi
évidemment c'est un coup très pressés
parce que forza 4 x 2 tu vois tu peux
pas parce qu'il y avait 17 ans prix
c'est pour ça qu'il va me demander à me
la joues et tu vas elle a joué avec eux
cinq avocats des cinq axes et un moment
il ya beaucoup de partir des 5 et 5 6 1
qui si je vais y ait sévi ce qu'avait
fait exactement ici c'est une position
qui est très très intéressante
ça c'est un jeu socialité de monsieur
mazet c'est vrai oui mais enfin on peut
dire que c'est une variante française
passe
beaucoup d'analysés des mangues tel
ajout mathieu la joue donc sébastien
nage ou en position mais qui est très
intéressante donc la fouace 3 km à l'est
de 4 500 l vélo a le regard fou ces cinq
ici c'est clair quant à l'ami la pause
avant tout prenait 3 elle regarde le
foot et 5 intermédiaires ou c5 il faut
être deux qu'est ce qui se passe il faut
calculer
bon c'est quoi ces fossés 5-fu prendre
dame prend cavaliers des quatre mais y'a
peut-être fou prend des quatre il ya un
clouage - l'a pas fait ah oui mais
l'inclura je suis pas obligé de prendre
la douche juste vous jouez machin mais
je sais pas ce que ça a donné
mais là en fait c'est juste un pion de
plus pour les noirs donc il fallait
peut-être quand même aller jouer le
fossé 5
pendant qu'en spéculer sur je ne sais
pas sur quel sujet j'ai complètement
raté où est passé il était en fait il
était en idée venue de ces quatre en
dessin qui est en c6 pascal a dû penser
qu'elles avaient faussé fou j'ai 5
pouces et 5 mai à baie d'alger 5 contre
attaque
j'ai un besoin de katia perdre le fil du
match l'aller qui lui a fait mal c'est
vrai et en même temps à katia joue
pratiquement tout le temps à 4 donc fait
change de stratégie au milieu de match
soit il essaie de s'adapter du jeu est
de 4 qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire je pense
que c'est le format 6 est prête pour ce
que je pense que le format est très
fatiguant oui c'est épuisant match comme
ça c'est pas s'il vient me dire combien
de moments critiques
les joueurs traversent pendant le match
tu vois les mamans du 10 août en choeur
ils s'arrêtent de battre tout simplement
tu vas spécifié dans deux voilà de
reprendre ses esprits de tout
recommencer
il y avait des acheteurs en ligne il
faut réveiller pita pita jamais le temps
ce que les parties s'enchaînent donc tu
n'as pas le temps de te poser un moment
donné tu es obligé d'enchaîner enchaîné
enchaîné enchaîné enchaîné le jargon que
le niveau de jeu est meilleur en trois
plus un jeu trouve finalement malgré le
déficit de temps elles ont réussi à
faire d'assez bonne partie mais j'avais
du mal à rentrer dans le match je pense
sur des peurs cela ils ont pris déjà ses
repères et ça m'inquiète quand tu as
tout à fait raison katrina elle n'a pas
fait une seule bonne partie avec les
blancs sur les trois mois ah ouais non
clairement là les kin la mise vraiment
mal parce que ça le cal a gagné c'était
un vrai hold à pain était complètement
foutu et là c'est la troisième partie
consécutive avec les blancs où elle est
moins bien mais genre pas moins un peu
moins bien elle est vraiment nettement
moins bien la sortie l'ouverture mais
regarde ce centre cette avalanche des
pions à la défaite 4 3 et 4 3 donc tout
est possible
j'arrive plus à se tourner plutôt d
ajouter 4 et 6 parce que je pense que
c'était l'idée oui un tas diallo regarde
pousser 4 mais bon mais c'est encore une
fois tu vois ces coûts sont faciles mais
en plus j'ai l'impression que tout
marche tellement la position est bonne
oui il faut ce 4e tour des vite
évidemment
donc on perd pas la pièce il ya des
tours a réussi un qui peuvent partir
maintenant à victor 1.4 et louvre ne
fout rien
j'ai du mal à trouver peut-être qu'il
faut que même je vais foncer 4 c'est
avec l'espoir de tout échange et des
tesnières cette finale qu'est ce que tu
en penses
c'est qu'être de prendre un des cinq
tout échange et d'un bac 4
ces tunnels temps de chien de garde et
les pièces sur l'échiquier
l'énergique y en a tellement
tellement peu de coûts pour les blancs
là c'est tellement dur je sais une autre
et dès ce soir était de sacrifier la
qualité des 510 est maintenant d'être si
j'arrive à gagner le pion en et 4 je
vais attaquer quelque chose je tourne
autour des 5 et prendre un et quatre
peut-être que ça ça peut tenir
est ce que tu penses que ça peut ça peut
être une solution
oui il faut trouver des ressources
et si j'aime bien pour poupée 500m bien
lorsque maintenant il peut avoir poussé
quatre peut-être un moment donné j'ai
pas quoi ça sert mais bon bon bon
baissier ceci pour fixer le gangbé
s'étaient allongés dans la diagonale
mais peut-être là dont on les change
tout qu'est ce t'en pense j'ai acheté
autour de 7
et voilà j'essaie de tenir des six
soirées pour bloquer c'est ce qu'elle
joue adjouffou des sièges très bien joué
et fausse car il faut faire voilà là
jusqu'à fait arica n'ont hélas les
vôtres en ce sens mieux
là les ventes sont mieux tu vois on
était en train de chanter les louanges
d'arica et la foule ou trois je pense
que c'est pour bien blindé la position à
elle fait jouer offensif adams est
direct c'est bien joué aussi
oui mais là j'aurais joué dans me 17,5
précision parce qu'il a compris
ben c'est bien joué je ne peux pas
prendre aux dames de saintes c'est voici
mairie qu'a laissées il a perdu le fil
des portiers le fou qui va relier ces
quatre là mais regardez le temps mais
repoussé huit aussi qui arrivent c'est
un miracle pour henri kassy à la tient
même si la position est peut-être
tenable objectivement tu penses que
maintenant si c'est très dur je prend sa
chance et hyper dur à cuire la voilà
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire un
coup droit
moi je suis là c'est ce qu'a fait y'a
pas de doute qu à vouloir fou six dames
david peut-être essien
numéro h7 ce cas c'est bien joué de la
part d'eric à retenir pour le moment ce
qui a beaucoup de joueurs qui auraient
perdu en perdant le fil comme ça qui
auraient vite perdu la partie
mon besoin de ramener le fou est ce
qu'il ya un moyen de jouer fou j'ai cinq
ans pourtant tu vois si tant il ya plus
de temps de temps un petit conseil de
quelqu'un qui joue beaucoup sur internet
répéter les mêmes coups c'est pas
forcément idiot en fait ne pas trop
réfléchir et juste faire damer 5 d'amd 5
oui mais c'est encore une fois tu vois
cet agrément d'une seconde j'ai
l'impression que ça ne permet pas
forcément d'avoir quelques secondes non
mais c'est juste pas tomber c'est juste
ne pas se poser de questions et de pas
tomber quoi les fondus de la part d'un
rica dans un deuxième temps mais c'est
vrai qu'elle fait des en fait elle gère
un peu mieux la maintenant gérer sur les
trois puissances celle inverse et arica
qui joue un peu mieux mais celle qui
vient fait un peu plus et combien de
temps un pour ce match là il nous reste
deux parties de partir d'accord d'accord
et qu'elle joue le double final cateau
c'est pas une mauvaise idée contre la
grande ville de l'est indienne c'est ça
que j'aime bien en fait j'aime pas les
questions est ce qu'elle voit jouer le
système avec ses 4 3 voilà ils ont vas
voir c'est une suite qui est très
flexible et 3 et permettent de mettre la
dame années 2000 m2 deux des trois voies
j'ai toujours eu du mal joué ses
positions là avec les deux couleurs
c'est vrai que maintenant les joueurs le
joue beaucoup mais moi quand j'ai arrêté
il ya 14 15 ans était assez peu joué ces
ouvertures là maintenant c'est vrai
qu'il y en a beaucoup de double enquête
au comme ça oui parce que tu es c'est
quelque part aussi de niveler la
préparation de ton adversaire tu vas
dans la green fees des gars tellement de
suite on l'a vu avec maxime qui est
quelque chose cette position à ses
positions à la perfection
mais même pour lui c'est difficile parce
que on le cible dans chaque partie
je sais pas combien d'heures il répète
oui oui parce que la green fees de
pratiquement dans chaque ligne je sais
pas combien de varien deviennent
concrètes il ya combien de nos coûts
mais a été obligée de trappes et
d'absolument tout parce que si tu te
trompes tu perd immédiatement
c'est pas une ouverture qui vous qui si
tu fais une erreur une imprécision sa
sage ou encore là dans la grünfeld dans
la nage dorff qu'on me prenez l'exemple
de maxime si tu trompes ces abandons
instantanée quasiment oui oui le prix
d'un coût est extrêmement d'une erreur
est extrêmement élevé est un disque par
exemple moi la danse ses positions là et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs je pense
qu'avec allégeant un blitz tu as une
gaffe c'est pas grave
bon c'est juste peut-être un pion oui
voilà
et encore ça peut même ne pas être un
pion j'existe en train de me poser la
question quand on a discuté ce qu'il
fallait jouer des quatre avec les noirs
ou pas bloquer le centre et aux pommes
et 5
c'est un peu mieux pour les blancs quand
même parce que les fouilles tape sur le
pion à 7 et je veux dire qu on est un
peu plus faible que le pion b
le plus souvent ce sont les échanges ses
faiblesses là tu sais je vais essayer de
lui l'un des deux protège le permettra
pour le moment mais il tape à deux pas
de suite
facile donc le tir doit doubler sur la
colonne à et justin a cavalé c4 est ce
que j'aurai pas de moyens d'attaquer
champions je lis franchement ce des
pulsions que je sens très malin je les
joue systématiquement mal c'est c'est
horrible pour moi j'arrive pas bien très
mauvais feeling mais j'ai encore une
fois tu sais pourquoi je le comprends
parce que pas de centres souvent pour
les joueurs amateurs
moi même je sais toi y'a pas de centria
de pion un pion dans l'adaption abattu
au centre est n'a pas du tout et le
centre et l'est pas défini et on a du
mal encore une fois à définir nos
objectifs
ouais non c'est galère
j'arrive maintenant expliqué à poser les
mots sur ce sentiment de malaise et
quand tu me le dis je le comprends tout
à fait puisqu'il ya des positions aussi
que je ne maîtrise pas du tout j'ai je
me suis posé la question mais pour
quelle raison est ce que c'est une à
explication à ces objectifs de celle ci
ses cavaliers à 5,5 pas très stable et 5
fu 4 j'aime bien son coup j'avais dît si
simple peut-être qu'elle foute est-ce
qu'on peut on peut prendre il faut
cesser ce fossé j'ai pas envie mais oui
mon cap sizun battre le fou tu pourras
plus contesté après we done d'essayer de
bien j'aime jouer je me suis posé la
question mais après comment est-ce qu'on
damas
qu'est ce qui se passe sur que vale à 5
et c'est quelque chose
attaf où j'ai deux dames des cinq échecs
à l'échangé des changes elle prend et
c'est pour ça qu'elle le fait dans cet
ordre là mais oui le cavalier à 5 va
être bizarre et assez un peu comme tu
l'avais prédit les noirs doivent hockey
au pire tu peux être fier qui a aidé 6
et 3 8 non elle prend du pion mlv tour à
lui à régler ouvert et b3 dans tous les
cas ils vont échanger ses faiblesses la
même temps après prendre des sièges
peut-être un tampon à 5o c'est
incroyable
l'admirable à 100 et je vois ça quand je
te disais toujours que moi c'est jouer
bien tu vois quand je suis fatigué oui
exactement le genre de gaffe que je fais
genre ya une pièce qui attaquaient genre
latour vian à 8 et j'oublie que je
devais la défendre j'y pense au début et
j'oublie 1 c'est typique le mont type de
gars fois que vient de faire à riga donc
je comprends tout à fait mais c'est
terrible de donner une caisse comme ça
ça c'est vraiment la fatigue oui
bon écoute il reste quatre minutes 10
dans le iii plus sain et c'est peut-être
le tournant du match si katia réussi à
gagner ici je pense qu'elle fait
vraiment tourner le match en sa faveur
donc ça c'est la dernière partie de ces
canards c'est la dernière mais je pense
que le break de deux points tu sais
enfin avec une faim de deux sessions
avec une gaffe comme ça pour clôturer ça
peut faire très mal
mentalement ça peut être une partie
colossal pour pouvoir y cas et cette
fois ci c'est mieux gérer de la part de
kia tient ou pas oui je pense que les
blancs une excellente position et tu
vois il faut pas être comme en doute ses
pions f5 que 5 ne représente pas
vraiment une menace est ce que ça a
l'air très très joli mais avec les deux
fous la caste des cinq les blancs tu es
fou controller beaucoup de choses je
n'étais pas sûr de la suite à donner
j'ai pas été sur deux dames prend dès 8
ans était tellement bien on apprend des
encore une fois c'est ma tendance
naturelle à ne pas échanger les dames
non mais c'est bizarre parce que ça
donne un coût gratuit en fait ça donne
tour à des 8
peut-être qu'elle veut juste l'échangé
c'est gagner le match
je ne sais pas si c'est vraiment
possible d'avoir une telle stratégie
tendant dans ce format là et là je
joignais une position très calme et il
lâché patients mais qu'est ce qui se
passe après les de 4.55 pour f4 aussi un
spa idiot oui non là cela n'a pas été
inspiré un dame prend des huit c'était
pas son meilleur coup là c'est en train
de tourner en faveur des noirs une
nouvelle fois petit à petit et il
voulait simplifier la position c'est
très naturel je comprends tout à fait
puisque tu vois il faut pas sous-estimer
la fatigue les pac eurêka et peut-être
aussi suite à la gaffe elle a voulu
assurer tu sais des fois tu as tu un
réflexe humain qui te sais qu'ils ont
dit au tennis tu joue petit bras tu sais
tu tapes moins fort dans la balle tu
essayes juste de la remettre dans le
court tuchan l'adversaire qui fait des
erreurs
tu te mets à trop attendre et du coup tu
leur mets dans le match je connaissais
pas du tout cette expression petit bras
oui ça même temps ceux ci aux échecs
pour toi comme on n'est pas en forme on
essaie de simplifier la position tu vois
confrérique a d'ailleurs joué dans les
portiers précédent de tenir un peu mais
là j'aime pas du tout ce que fait
catherine un oui je voulais dire le
cavaliere ne plaît pas du tout donc la
10e tête de leur place et peut-être qu'à
l'aller c'est 3d car attention elle doit
se faire échanger et regarde le pion ya
le cavalier qui peut arriver en f3
cavaliers ou 5
ouais car il est des trois aussi là les
cases ça va être une égalisation pour
arica il a pu ainsi 5,9 les paquets elle
est inquiète pour les mômes en effet
faire caca je pense qu'il ya là pas de
calais qui va arriver
5 ces cavaliers hélas c'est la quatrième
c'est la quatrième à les kings
consécutifs qui se passe très mal et là
il ya tout reprend des cinq qui avaient
lieu deux cavaliers français quelqu'un
et ça va être à temps il reste 50
secondes là moi si je suis katia je
laisse tourner la pendule après une
partie pareil et je repars en bullet et
c'est parce qu'elle va faire à
l'abandonner direct une partie une
partie plus élevé gagnant puisque
probablement et là elle n'est pas si
confiante je sais un vol est je la
comprends mais faut vraiment qu'elle
trouve quelque chose à la pause contre
l'aller qui n'a là on va avoir une pause
de cinq minutes
boulette c'est extrêmement important
maurel n'a pas le choix il faut
absolument qu'elle trouve
qu'elles trouvent une option uniquement
à crabes excuser d absolument
extraordinaire j'ai l'impression que
quelles que soient les voitures
maintenant on peut jouer h 4 et il a vu
le même match c'est un hangar bon
candidat me sens fort sans jeu des
quatre avec cette structure c4 des trois
fours des deux ans jouets 3 on mettait
les pieds les gâter ont fait jusqu'à
toucher quatre jours mais là j'aime bien
encore une fois la position de noir dès
qu'il ya le centre j'ai peut-être j'ai
une tendance à surestimer well et le
contrôle et pion au centre pas j'ai le
même problème ray mais bon là c'est pas
mal ce qu'elle a fait avec les blancs et
qui a valu à trois je m'étais pas rendu
compte de la puissance du coup mais
c'est vrai quand tu fais ces cas du coup
pris ce qu'ils avaient pensé capture
touche aux 5 immédiatement il faut
peut-être jeu je n'aurais pas pris 1 6 4
je sais c'est encore une fois tu as très
bien décrit donc il faut qu'elle ait cas
mais maintenant quand tu fais dame prend
ya plus les caves alliage 5 eu donc
c'était tu veux dire que c'est l'idée
derrière le kw/h 4 non là c'est cool
pour les blancs forcément on voit bien
les fous x 6 pour le moment ce n'est pas
une menace mais on prend des cinq y
avait des points il faut prendre un set
en été mais qui a été barrée d'un
massage très bien joué fauché quatre
jeunes bien aussi poursuites d'après
vous qu'est ce que tu vas laisser quatre
avec tempo quand même hein il faut et
d'auto rien te sens vraiment il y en a
c'est peut-être je peux pas t'en tfo et
2 x 6 ouais ok ça a l'air d'être assez
logique qu'avaient les dessins qu'après
parce que la dame et les pur sang
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire chier le
temps qu à chaque page de google et
d'amd deux tons en lui
kameneff 600 prises qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire
ça fait deux c'est hyper hyper
surprenant parce que c'est au moment où
arica a gaffé qu'on pensait que le match
tournait en faveur de katia katia
commença à faire absolument n'importe
quoi ce soit dans la partie précédente
ou dans celle là en réalité elle en
train de faire cadeau de deux points à
rica mais tu vois on n'a pas beaucoup
d'expérience des six décès serait bien
joué en plus les impôts mais pas tout à
fait parce que ça me ferait peut-être
quelques chances jamais travaillé 1,8 à
délier à 17
tu as tu as très bien
il s'agit peut-être c'est une loi ça me
tient très bien dit qu'il fallait
tourner la pendule et jouer le bol est l
fallait laisser il fallait temporisé
fallait laisser tourner moi voilà il ya
juste des c'est des fous pranger set
j'ai envie de te dire c'est oui y'a pas
la 17e' la foudre et 17 mai tiré sa
rentrée chassés d'iran et on essaie
d'expliquer à tous très peur mais
y'avait vous prend 17 que j'ai raté tu
vois c'est ok là c'est le petit moment
tu vois où arica des fois quand elle
était gagnante elle a pu se mettre à
paniquer pour pas grand chose aux gens
là qui a valu aux trois laisse tout
reprendre cette pourquoi et ça y est ça
rica qui paniquait les gens beaucoup
mieux au temps mon audition gagnante à
hilard était sûr que j'ai captera cheikh
voilà j'essaie d'expliquer le cavalier
de 5
toujours calé pour un shérif libre ont
forcé l art est un échec intermédiaire
mais bon pour l'instant les banques
tiennent même si leurs positions alors
c'est quand même cata pour les je sais
pas comment tu tiens ça avec les noirs
ça reste dur il faut jouir
il faut gb 4 quel c3 et sur soie suite
assure fois chute je ne sais pas
il faut prendre des cinq dames g7 matin
à rennes on sait ça elle a failli perdre
le contrôle donc du coup m6 mais bon tu
peux même pas jouer fois que cette la
dame en acier cette emprise donc tu peux
pas prendre à cavalier c'est fox est
donc ça il faut faire quelque chose
le fuyard partir de huit jours fois
chute quand j'ai la foule de 5,5
ok ça continue d'asia dé fond bien là
elle aurait pu perdre sur le champ et en
même temps il ne reste que dix secondes
est ce que rcar à craquer aya pasdaran
ondam huit noms hier à tours et fuite et
je pensais de huit tours à je suis tout
et aux machines on arrête je vois pas
dans quel monde on défend d'être foire
dame b 2 manon tribune très gelé des
poubelles deux derniers cas là c'est là
c'est la même chose dans comment y
remédier si la france est ici cela n'y a
plus de coup ouais non careca remporte
du coup cette manche
eric a remporté cette manche way et
katia friot à une très mauvaise décision
dans la partie précédente de pas de
palais se reposer elle est partie à
l'aller énervés l'un ça c'est au tour de
la caméra j'ai pu regarder surtout que
la deuxième caméras de sécurité où on
voit voit la pièce entière et elle est
partie très énervé à katia normalement
oui oui mais voilà oui c'est les
conseils déco tué de l'eau froide sur
les visages surtout tu vas c'est très
important et 2c de faire quelques
exercices de respiration j'ai écouté ce
que tu connais justine henin la joueuse
de tennis
oui oui j'ai écouté une interview d'elle
il n'y a pas si longtemps elle expliqué
fiel parler de djokovic qui revenait des
vestiaires beaucoup plus fort après le
deuxième set
ont-ils gardé de 7,0 l is equally ce
qu'elle faisait parfois c'est
aller prendre une douche froide dans les
vestiaires quand elle prenait une pause
toilette aller très vite se mettre de
l'eau froide sur tout le corps en fête
de l'eau glacée sur tout le corps et
qu'elle revenait sur le court et que ça
l'était beaucoup et que c'est quelque
chose que les joueurs de tennis fond et
c'est vrai qu'aux échecs c'est aussi un
truc de se mettre de l'eau froide sur le
visage oui mais c'est de l'eau froide
sur visage c'est une chose mais ce
conseil de d'ailleurs l'histoire de
justine henin et elle est très
pertinente
d'ailleurs bien pour les échecs parce
que tu sais il me semble que je lis à
très très longtemps mais dans les
revenus et chicken c'était une suite est
un rituel de 1 à policarpo pratiquement
avait un chèque parti il prenait des
douches contraste est donc en fait c'est
comme ça que tu réveilles ton corps donc
de choix d' je réitère nature et ton
corps réagit et ton esprit réagi oui
c'est extrêmement important en fait si
je me souviens à la suite de cette
interview j'étais très jeune je sais pas
j'avais 14 ans je me suis dit bon je
vais avoir une discipline d'assiette jeu
je me suis jeté dans la mer jaune
faisait 10 degrés je suis resté j'espère
une vingtaine de minutes avec les
urgences à la clé l'auteur du coup je
vais te faire la peau 40 degrés mais oui
ça m'a permis d'appliquer ma vision des
choses à ce moment là mais aussi de
comprendre à quel point si elle aura
pour un autre court mais moi sachez
qu'il est très important
la dimension physique mais que je
réussis introduire que plus tu as donc
là c'est possible que réellement elle
soit parti dans la salle de bain pour
pour se rafraîchir un petit peu et a
récupéré un petit peu d'énergie et
d'attention s'ils ont dû l'être en plus
là c'est vraiment peu pour la peine les
gaffes peuvent peuvent plus voir il faut
vraiment réussir être attentif et bien
voir l'échiquier ce qui est plus
toujours le cas après 2h30 de jeu la
médaille d'or au québec toi que je sais
celle ci rende des comptes comme j'ai
commenté le match précédent c'est qu'en
fait je n'ai jamais joué une partie de
boules est de ma vie
je pense jamais aucune expérience donc
est ce qu il ya de véritables stratégies
peut-être d'expérience j'imagine que
j'étais peut-être que de faire des prix
moore ou d'avoir une ouverture tu sais
que tu connais les 20 kw en avance ouais
ouais il faut il faut être malin juste
pas trop comment dire mais oui il ya des
gens qui ont des ouvertures spéciale
pour le bullet moi je sais que joue bien
les finales donc j'essaye de rentrer
dans des finales si je peux et puis et
puis de jouer sur l'instinct mais oui
c'est différent faut avoir des positions
aussi tu peux jouer vite tu peux faire
des prêts move mais après ça joue
vraiment sur l'acuité eux il ya des
jours où tu vois vite et il ya des jours
où tu vois pas vite je sais pas trop
comment dire quoi mais ça explique en
fait très très bien l'état de forme de
joie parce que même dans les partis
classiques
tu vois il ya des jours au dessus en
fait souvent ça joue même si dans les
partis classiques sur les tactiques qui
sont très simples oui tout va et il sait
c'est la caractéristique du bullet je
pense tu vois il faut faut pas gâcher et
tu vois un truc bête je veux je peux je
sais pas si je peux te prendre une
position mais tu vois qu'on n'était pas
en forme en bullet bon ça va être dur de
mettre une position mais je sais pas tu
vois si on avait cette position là
dessus il faut que s'il mais qu'il fasse
d'un f4 pour proposer l'échangé dame que
tu vois tout de suite en fait dit le
propose et je veux dire par là quand tu
es fatigué ou quand tu es peut encore
vous quant à plus de lucidité ces genres
de choses qui peuvent ne plus devenir
automatique est faux que des trucs aussi
simple soit tout le temps automatique
je sais pas il ya un fou qui vient f4 en
face de tadamoun quoi faut que tu vois
que ça attaque tabac annoncée cet mais
faut que tu vois tout de suite en fait
oui ce sont des automatismes qui elle ne
me semble pas de château propre jeu
je me pose tu vois je regarde la
position à j'essaie d'avoir une
stratégie il
il est blanc déjà joué il faut il faut
il faut vraiment que tout toutes les
menaces en 1 ou les menaces de
fourchette en fait elles deviennent
automatiquement sont à y penser pour
pouvoir te concentrer sur ta partie si
tu commence à rater ça une deux trois
fois c'est terminé en fait tu prends
l'eau et en même temps à une maîtrise de
soi aussi très importante
tu vois je pense que je n'ai pas perdre
le contrôle de ne pas tout envoyer 2
de se reprendre c'est même cette cadence
là là comme ils disent dans le chatt
celui qui est vraiment impressionnant
c'est hikaru il est vraiment capable de
jouer en bullet en discutant avec son
chat et en le faisant pendant des heures
sans être fatigué je sais pas comment il
fait en fait à moi je sais pas en fait
la seule expérience que j'ai eues dans
dans ce genre même exercice mais le banc
terre contre les réseaux ferroviaires
époque il ya deux ans de plus je peux
être belge pratiquement le mur joueurs
et je me suis rendu compte que c'était
pas du tout naturel pour moi il peut
être dû à mon éducation il ya un job et
je ne vois pas le jeu de la même façon
donc du coup je ne peux pas à parler y
réfléchir en même temps c'est
extrêmement difficile et alors j'ai du
mal à envisager de le faire avec une
minute à la pendule non mais je sais pas
honnêtement il carouge sais pas comment
il fait il doit voir les choses
tellement vite
enfin il faut qu'il ait une telle
rapidité d'esprit pour pouvoir le faire
que ça doit juste voilà il n'a pas le
cerveau qui est fait comme comme les
autres en fait c'est pas possible ça va
plus vite chez lui que chez les
personnes normales en fait c'est même un
même temps peut-être que c'était un
véritable pionnier du jeu c'est de cette
discipline là je sais que karoutchi par
jour dans ses cadences là je suis
toujours extraordinaire mais quand on
commence si plus tôt il était fort mais
je sais comment vrai joueur américain de
50 dans les open américain tellement de
temps et de blitz entre les deux rondes
voilà c'était un véritable pionnier est
probablement le premier du streaming
voici qui a révolutionné quelque part
aussi le cette discipline ça et il a
forcément acquis des compétences c'est
comme eux les théories de l'évolution ce
que tu vas forcément être quérir si tu
va survivre
peut-être qu'en devenir plus fort voilà
sur dans ce champ d'application et moi
je vois que je suis comme en crocodile
je reste le même mais je sais pas si je
vais survivre jusqu'à downsizing sigmax
il peut faire pareil mais maxime non
moins qu enfin beaucoup moins qu'ils
karua c'est pour le bullet beaucoup
moins et maxime il fatigue aussi alors
qu'ils car où tu as l'impression qui
n'est jamais fatigué ça ça aussi c'est
incroyable a l'impression qu'il peut
jouer à dix heures d'affilée qui réussit
toujours à parler
en fait c'est tout ce que tu veux dire
qu'elle n'a jamais les baisses de régime
donc sa concentration à un niveau
extrêmement stable ouais
ou alors il a tellement pas besoin de se
concentrer pour le faire avec moi c'est
plutôt comme ça que je vois c'est que
c'est tellement facile pour lui la même
pas vraiment besoin de se concentrer un
changement d'ouverture pour arica oui
allez le boulet ça mais c'est toujours
et c'est juste une autre forme
un autre ordre de croquis à transposer
ça fait avec kavala ccias marrant qui
allait changer calais qui allait
modifier sa sont allés keane malgré les
bons résultats elle a dû penser que
katia vais peut-être régler ça à la mi
temps
bon je sais pas je ne sais même pas
comment on va arriver à le calculer on
va voir non mais là faut regarder les
coûts en plus ce qui se passe et on va
pas on va pas penser à des variantes on
va voir et 5e d'ailleurs volé deux
points 5 5
c'est une idée stratégique très
important c'est que c'est pas si mal et
d'échangés c'est juste sur la suite
tu vois là ils ont tout les deux ratés
cavaliers prend aucun attrait la vue
katia juste après high avec avait lieu
car je pense bout du compte les huit qui
prend des deux s'attaquer à la tour oui
oui et tu vas katia la vie joue aidé à
me de est là c'est sûr qu'elle laquelle
a vu ça ce qui est horrible en fait
c'est quand tu as les noirs et que ton
adversaire fait vite dames 2 tu comprend
immédiatement que tu as raté cavaliers
prendre quatre tu le sens en fait c'est
ça qui est dur en bullet c'est que tu
peux voir beaucoup de choses à
retardement fia tout le temps un coup en
retardant la partie et même temps tu as
et si je devais
choisir j'aurais pris les noirs ici ce
qu'elle est à 5 x 6 je sais pas d'âme
cette d'un cavalier h 4 et les coûts
sans fassiez jamais oublier tu es ce que
j'ai dit on mais les prix en g3 j'aurais
pas de quai à angers 3 mais c'est
peut-être une très bonne décision
on va voir l'aca cela ça se joue dans la
tête là ça se joue sur sur les petits
coups ali hafsi mco qui part mais tu
vois là il ya aussi le pion à 7 qui peut
tomber à un moment donné ça peut faire
plaisir ce genre de petites menaces il y
en a souvent qu'elle valait à 4
cavalaire ce que la 4l et c5 dans sa
position la siagne et le oui à la
jonquera 4 après le truc qui est bon en
bulles est ce que tu aimes pas c'est que
ce soit ton roi qui se fasse attaquer et
là c'est vrai que de se prendre ça c'est
plutôt à l'avantagé des noirs
normalement mais bon 3 tu vas lagaf et
katia et ça commence à faire l'écart ça
fait plus deux pour consacrer l écart se
creuse là elle creuse assez marrant un
sécateur qui a craqué en premier ses
katas qui a craqué en premier
non elle changer un peu de stratégie oui
ils n'ont pas forcément par rapport à
dater d'avant
rebecca répète le film catholique elle
jouait 5,4 très bien ce qu'est ce qu'il
faut j'ai ses quatre tours de 8 échanges
du coup elle va reprendre quoi est ce
que c'est vrai maintenant oui parce que
je me disais oui que les points à 4 sera
faible
et oui car et les c4 que valéo 3,6
réussissent à faire cavalier ces six
tours ces huit noms et les huit tours de
8 jeunes sûrement que les schistes ce
n'est pas possible
elle pensait sur l'accueil social ce qui
avec avait les trois tu sais quoi mais
là c'est hyper honnêtement c'est hyper
dangereux pour les noirs parce que tu as
tellement deux fourchettes possibles
genre d'ami 8 ya eu des six dames c'est
cette ya peut-être cavaliers des six
même l a pas fait c'est tellement encore
une fois je sais tellement compliqué de
donner des conseils je sais que moi même
je suis pétrifié dans ce genre de
situation là c'est là là là pour jouer
vite et bien là c'est qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait faut protéger les pions cinq
tours des sacs comment damas et je suis
je suis en panique 30 secondes lui dans
ma 5 c'est très bien et c'est qu'amélie
est on a oublié
ouais on a posé mais c'était c'est
probablement aussi une des changes est
ce qu'elle va entrer en d2 ouais mais
foix iii à elle perd le contrôle la
mefou à 3.635 elle vient peut-être de
trois jeux c'est faux 5 3 a signé
scellier web de créer cinq cavaliers des
cats pour véhiculer les b4y way s'est
attaché au québec quatre bien jouer pour
prendre 2 vient voir des fous ces huit
fou prend bessette maintenant qui vont
tomber
comment est-ce qu'on ne peut créer un
couloir vous 17 septembre
je peux pas prendre ouais si ça va être
prison qui stopperont bessette caroline
a en plus et enlève cette si tu as la
presse donc je ne sais pas peut-être
qu'elle faisait elle veut donner un
électeur peut tuer c'est pas possible de
prendre la fuite
je vois plus rien oui bon big 4 elle
menace quoi elle menace rien mais a pris
quand même à temps c'est quoi s'attendre
ouais mais ce que c'est pas qui est
mieux ici en réalité peut-être un
électorat 8 c'est bien jouer où elle
passe derrière et qui a rallié prend 1,4
maintenant et danser les blancs qui sont
mieux c'est les blancs qui sont mieux
c'est sûr ses pions de plus je peux pas
jouer quelque chose comme à troyes que
valait 7 2 et 1
c'est la seule chance pratique
aimer ça va tellement vite mon coeur a
tancé cavalli tourbe et moi toi tous les
échecs et si je tour à cette cavale et
b5
j'aime déco c'est bien joué mais les
blancs sont complètement gagnant ouais
ça peut faire trois points d'écart ça
peut commencer à devenir chrétien
combien de temps on a combien de partis
il ya huit ou neuf parties général tient
mais là tu vois c'est là c'est une
partie qui dure vraiment très longtemps
puisqu'il ya beaucoup de coups avec le
rajout c'est une partie qui peut en
compter qui peut compter double parce
qu'on est déjà à 60 coups qu'elle veut
pas et en plus on peut allègrement des
bakchichs allait rentrer là dedans que
tu as mon j'étais désespéré de toute
façon de prendre une décision
surtout avec deux secondes à la pendule
donc trois points d'accord maintenant je
sens maintenant ça fait 3 points et ça à
faire 17 et du coup je pense que si
harry qui a gagné cette partie plus 4 ce
sera terminé à
almira vont pas mathématiquement mais ça
va être quasiment quasiment fini faut
absolument que katia l'emportent mais
arica semble juste plus forts en bulles
est un est la plus des lots déjà
simplement bullet il ya 80 points elo
d'écart et ça semble être plus son truc
oui mais ça veut dire qu'elles sont très
moi c'est un jeu probablement et et joue
pas mal hein goulette mais s'entraîne
des matches d'entraînement et ça a
clairement joué en sa faveur
ouais ça se voit qu'elle est quand tu
sais j'ai remarqué qu'elle est le le
truc qui me fait me remarquer qu'elle
est vraiment bien
c'est à la fin quand il ya eu clouage
elle a très vite vu tour à six tours à 7
km et b5 et ça c'est genre de réflexe de
bull est en fait moi je les verrai si je
veux dire par là que tu vois les
rentrées dedans volontairement et ça se
voit qu'elle connaissait le schéma tu
vois elle n'a pas paniqué elle est
rentrée elle est allée dans quoi oui
mais c'est tout ce que voulait dire
c'est moi j'ai vu ça veut dire que ce
n'est pas compliqué parce que de bettié
de gérer tous ces trucs là ouais mais
oui nommé je comprends ce que tu veux
dire c'est bien celui des couples mêmes
qui avance qui a commencé bien plus tôt
ouais c'est ça c'est que tu avais
lappion passé là bas il fallait le
contrôler il fallait le gérer
saberi tu vois là encore regarde à
l'envoi b6 pour x 6 tu vois je ça sent
qu'elle est bien pour les petites rides
quoi c'est creux est ce que si je vais
réussir à stabiliser un sens je voulais
dire oui 5
alors la tête reprend 4 c'était un prix
et ce soit dans les emprisonnements
leucate en clair peut-être encore
quelque chose tu vois si j'aime bien moi
je prends maintenant 5 après si tu joues
tu auras chutent maintenant je peux
jouer 5
c'est vrai c'est vrai ça peut être
dangereux fou et 4.4 tour de 2 3 4 après
qu'est ce que tu fais c'est toujours
génial non
jef jel stores h4 c'est ça ouais bon ça
s'arrête m'est avis il y avait animé par
roger 5 x 3 mais bon ça ce sont des
analyses portent des parties agissent je
sais pas ça marche et c'est pourquoi
prend fou 3 c'était plus pour le piège
mais j'ai pas eue c'était bien et
comment évoluer cette position d'un
tellement compliqué devant l'émoi
raisons elles sont pas de pures de plus
non ça va être mieux pour les blancs
parce que le roi noir il est il est
complètement bloqué wet est toujours
beaucoup plus d'espacés mais tu vois il
temporise je sais pas je trouve qu'elle
a des bons réflexes pour le bullet à
jouer peut-être pas les meilleurs coups
un bien sûr ce que c'est c'est une
cadence spécialement le voyage c'est ça
ou extraordinaire un rituel s'est
activée je sais pas assez fait des trucs
bon là ça va pas ça va pas passer pour
revenir un quart temps je passe
katia va gagner c'est sûr ça à papa
c'est celle là là ça y est c'est matt
merican me semble hors de meilleurs
réflexes de bullet mais bon attention ce
qui a le plus sain qui change aussi pas
mal de chose qu'est ce qu'elle fait dans
quel esternay maison house moi j'aurais
jamais fait ça j'ai passé réflexe à la
barre - tu récupères attirer que p
et oui mais c'est bien joué parce que tu
viens de perdre une partie c'était chaud
tu as eu de la défense à faire et tu
récupères 10 secondes avant de te lancer
dans la prochaine partie c'est bien tu y
aller elle est plus plus maligne arica
pour ce petit truc là on va voir si ça
lui sourit katia change de stratégie
donc elle a joué des 5 parce que les
deux parties dans le double fine gâteau
avec ses 5 ne sont pas passées comme
elles le volet et donc regarde
c'était une très très bonne idée
ces trois yeux qui attraperont et aux
quatre dit mme hallé bim et ben voilà
mais ça m'a l'air complètement gagnant
ah ouais ça laisse arrière terrifiant il
n'y a pas un trick avec un échec sur la
grande diagonale ou un truc comme ça
la messe est qu'elle couche super bien
joué j'ai incroyable tu vois je suis pas
si évident de trouver ce genre de coups
en boulettes
je soutiens tout simplement de cavaliers
oui il transfère aussi la dame
potentiellement un f6 tu sais pour
lesquels aucun relief trois à temps pour
le moment où elle a rien de plus et
pierrick hallain réussit quand même à a
su nous a laissés ici et l'activité des
pièces mais il faut vraiment regarder
comme ça voilà une position surtout
quand il n'y a pas davantage matériel
sélective étaient des pièces qui est
déterminante
en tout cas pour le moment
si je prends tout simplement ce qu'est
ce que ce patch donc elle tu vois et
laisser que les tenants mais c'est un
coup pas de désespoir mais c'est un coup
très pratique et l'essai de libérer ses
plaies attendre d'être deux pour
l'instant il ya la mannschaft qui est un
prise je perds 2 un homme d'un premier
il prend un des deux voyages et les
intermédiaires
il est en train de calculer les nike a
priori 4
elle peut faire je pensais qu'ils
allaient faire dame prend aux 4,4 elle
transpose dans cette finale
elle va prendre un c4 alors attends faut
vite faire tourner un tour d'essai que
si elles peuvent sauvegarder la très
bien je n'aurai qu'à 34 ans et la tour
qui va arriver en 17 et moi et alors
c'est pas mal avec le foot tu vois tu
peux le garder à 9 600 h 8 et ce matin
très bien joué de la part de ketchup
je suis pour ces gadgets bien c'est bien
joué pour bessette sûrement mais à ces
deux tours prévus six c1 dames tu arrive
jamais à mater katia qui va revenir
c'est de ces 2 way et g5 ok c'est bien
tenter parce que c'est un il va faire
qu'il prend h7 keller c'était il y avait
tout simplement mis fois je suis tu
oui oui non ça ce n'est meilleur c'était
une chance pratique quoi ça pouvait
faire voir on sait jamais catherine day
là ça va ça va faire le point c'est sûr
donc neuf secondes mais attend à huy il
ya tellement que temps mais bon comme
elle avait un tâche matériel est décisif
dans la série à ces trois-là bien placé
la dame pour éviter les échecs
je sais pas comment d'or après des
matchs pareils
après avoir vu quelques dames sur
l'échiquier gens m'abordent couleurs
au v6 faute d'être à essayer d'en mettre
deux normalement ça craque un peu comme
costa ricain ça change un peu trop
d'ouverture attention c'est le meilleur
ordre de coûts avec les blancs contre
mais c'est un système raid sur cette
oeuvre
et du coup c'est une très très belle
française fois ci c'est une idée
stratégique il faut échanger les faux
elle va jouer comment alors oui c'est ça
qui a pu on prend b6 oui c'est ça que
moi je perds toujours pas mais tu veux
quand même garder cette option ne
reprendre que pioncer chaque mets
chinois 15 secondes
elle a dépensé 15 secondes dans
l'ouverture c'est beaucoup pour moi
aujourd'hui pour jouer un truc aussi
pourri h4 et h5 en quatre sets serrés
prix elle est là maintenant
ouais c'était joie emmanuel value force
et puis on prend pions prend elle va les
changer colonnes à elle va pouvoir faire
d'un prend à huit est rentré colonna
c'est pas sûr qu'avec les blancs tu
réussisses attaque et mat
un cavalier prend alors ça ça ça
m'étonne que beaucoup tu vois mais je
sais il faut créer du contre jeu dans
cette position là ce qui est pas aidé
ben tu vois la tourache quatre tours
j'ai quatre sets tu peux plus rauque et
qu'est ce que tu veux faire dans sa
position ferme et fuites non wear waste
c'est très compliqué aussi après fouille
faite tu vois c'est est forcé de revenir
je vois ça va arriver car et libé 5 ça
va arriver de partout un carré lisse et
2 qui est des quatre que j'ai raté déjà
trop court sur l'échiquier j'allais vous
oui les plans qu'est ce qu'il faut j'ai
fait ce qu'elle saura si c'est vrai ce
qu'elle veut les reprendre les salahi
lama vit très bien comme des 8° c sais
pas si je suis assez fou s'est tenue en
pur rock
t'es pas c'est pas ça semblait ça semble
être pas loin de gains mais au final qui
est mieux ici ça serait pas les noirs
finalement parce que tu vas récupérer h5
tu vas en voyage quand même état le
centre bell joue très très bien qu'elle
a compris qu'elle va perdre de points
donc elle doit créer
elle a très très bien joué alors elle a
tout fait et à une vitesse absolument
incroyable à calais b 4 et 6 soit là
l'enchaîner elle enchaîné je sais pas
combien de quoi tempo même temps à temps
il ya pas cavalier prend et fois cette
juste pour aller dame et au bon là juste
eu pranger 5e mais avait h trois jeunes
ont caillassé 5 ou sap a été vue elle
agacée de fouet mais l'autre à barika
l'a pas vu et roy g2 est fou prend des
huit cavaliers prend et sous des
couettes rochus décathlon nettement 4 6
5 et ça égalise
oh c'est incroyable il ya eu un coup de
mou de katia elle s'est repris le second
souffle et faire accueil qui changent de
stratégie encore une fois elle ne veut
plus jouer des bleus fait un gâteau donc
ces quatre ça fait partie de son
répertoire
alors il reste il reste deux ou trois
parties un avenir à deux trois parties
hockey bien je viens de temps à la
peinture
il reste 7 minutes ça peut faire ça peut
faire deux parties si ces deux longues
parties ça peut en faire trois on peut
pas vraiment savoir
mais en tout cas c'est très très chaud
c'est très serré c'est un match très
serré
la chair de poule bon allez comme ça
parce que c'est une amie qui est très
proche et qui gagnent ce match mais
voilà que caracas est un adversaire très
digne voilà que ce soit l'une ou l'autre
qui se qualifiait ils ont tout les deux
mérité un franchement ça a bien joué
tout le long et ce qu'elle va prendre
deux et faire ses cinq ans elle va
réussir à bloquer les cases noires et
avoir un bon refuge
oui mais même temps me donne de très
bien jouer je veux jouer des quatre fois
ci c'est plutôt bon
ouais mais c'est un malin ou pas j'en
sais rien et coûte la cw b3 encore une
fois des 4l obtenu quelque chose à rica
le thème est séduite c'est bien joué
peut-être pour remettre le fourbe et 7
ouais c'est pas mal joué ça oui mais en
même temps j'aime bien aussi comment
vous avez un cas elle a doublé sur la
commande des jeux mais je me disais est
ce que je pourrais doublé sur la commune
est fait jouer cinq sets 5-7 ans et un
plan aussi qui est très intéressant
peut-être même qu'il pouvait le faire
avant mais elles menacent le pion comme
elle veut prendre en full quatre ans
mais après il ya des princes et 5
juillet le clouage et je prendrai en d6
classe à part elle va faire des branches
prends et je vous en prie pages comment
indécise comme m qui va tout est changé
mais du coup elle va prendre à 2 à la
fin en tout cas elle avait un gros
retard à la pendule et l'aef s'inclinant
5 très bien joué et d'un médecin que je
pense aller on échange les dames à des 5
ou ça c'est dangereux où ça c'est genre
de coups y perdre en jouant bullet ivg
déjoué tour à cinq corps à sa queue 65.3
à france 3 et puis on tour prend aux
c'était hyper dangereux le coup
intermédiaire des cinq à la jouer avec
le feu je vous tourner car toi ça te ça
mais si j'arrive bien tout simplement
fausse 3 comme torres après que sheikh
abandon
oui c'était une gaffe au fait mes
dessins qui saturent à ces genres quand
tu me demandais tout à l'heure les la
différence entre le du latou pas comme
t'as pas le temps de calculer genre de
truc dangereux tu essayes de l'éviter
mais bon facile à dire
donc est ce qu il nous reste une partie
aux deux parties on va le savoir
en tout cas si harry cagan il en reste
une
en tous les cas oui mais par exemple si
c'est le match était bon et qu il est
vrai ils font nul à la dernière partie
qui gueulent thiam ainsi à égalité par
exemple que katia gagne et la dernière
partie fond de caisse créée l'année
dernière en tout cas cette année y'a pas
encore le cas de figure mais l'année
dernière il y avait quatre parties en
bullet appréhender partage et je pense
qu'il va aller
est-ce qu'on peut jouer h4 et c'est
quand même mon chèque à penser si
c'était elle se remet mal autant moi je
voulais pas prendre un fichier ce
vraiment si c'est des vols des pièces
mais 4,9 ou là ça arrive de partout la
barre est terrible pour les blancs
presque un dragon qui a mal tourné oui
on apprend des cavaliers y avait quatre
et qui protège les points 2 oui il
devrait placer ses pièces quête des
quatre j'aime bien damas 5 2 nouveaux et
du coup prendre six à ce moment là mais
là je fais pas du coup jouer h4 il faut
un jouet vitesse 6 h 14 5 7 6 6 et 6
dans la quatre vingt quatre salmona sera
ici quand même bête trois dames à
craquer et l'ont peut-être à 5 à 4 je
préférais ton idée de faire h4h and
jouer l'attaqué est plutôt que d'une
construction dans ces trois là on
passait mal bon je pense que oui
sa tension à cavaler à 4,1 et ya pas qu
il m'a dit à cathy si elle le fait pas
en tout cas le cas il va pouvoir revenir
en d5 s'étudie canada cadre j'ai même
pas vu kakule gouin en fait j 4 avant ça
paraissait plus forts dans le prix
emmanuel va prendre maintenant il doit
prendre le cavalier pour éviter qu'il
varie ses droits mais quelle est cette
fois ci menace c'est vrai d'ailleurs au
fond des trois voies est roi tout est
protégé bon et reste qu'en quelques
menace tour des deux mais je protège en
programme problème si soir si tu mates
ou pas avec les blonds roux h 6 min mais
je vais protéger mais samassa va te
regarde et des recettes dame g7 est donc
ce sera la dernière à rome comme match
donc ça va aller au bout on spartoo il
reste une 30 ça y est c'est la dernière
partie c'est la der des der on se fait
du côté de katia nom risque on reste on
a les calmes comme ça du coup ses côtés
car j'ai du mal ces corps expliqué wii
devient que le petit parfois oui
du coup c'est un est ce qu'on peut faire
est ce qu'on peut faire mieux le très
vite en boulettes que je suis dit là
elles sont parties pour le ca du reims
accueillera les minutes 30
tu préférais ans voire quatre deux
parties oui j'en viens maintenant que
j'ai pris goût oui je me devrais je sais
c'est comme le cinquième set
moi je veux le temps que durera
allez c'est qui c'est qui qu'a été
devant dans ses positions de cette
structure là on en a eu qu'une seule
c'était la partie précédente
et c'est plutôt un ricain qui avait
dominé bath est là où katerina nash et
oui il avait du mal un peu à regrouper
ses pièces et la gâcher la priant de 4
ce qui était bien mais après donc quand
ces structures là qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire il va prendre avec le pion faut
aussi se probablement oui qu'est ce que
j'allais être bien de jouer des parties
comme ça non c'est qu'elle a été quel
bonheur en fait sur food ssl va prendre
un effet prendre un fait quatre donc
j'ai une autre théorie ce qu'elle peut
prendre du fou ça paraissait bizarre est
inégal à dahmane des deux chic fou 5,5
ça y est c'est fini il ya plus de temps
toujours à dans cette partie almira
c'est la banda se décident mois en
appelé les ambulances attend qui est
mieux y'a pion de plus pour les noirs
énième qu'elle puisse pour les noirs oui
c'est vrai que j'ai le plan à deux
meilleurs le fonds est un des six est
extrêmement voyage 5 qui aie aie aie
revoit fauché quatre avec les dettes
enfin c'est bien joué mais en même temps
le jeu il faut c'est qu'à 3 h 8 commenté
bref cet après à toi par contre est
changé je pense était pas bon je pensais
qu'elle voulait food et royal 5au le
match qui est en train de tourner en la
faveur de katia là il faut qu'elles
trouvent un coup handicap qui a bloqué
katia qui intègre française donc ça
parle tellement bien encore très bien
chanté la marseillaise maintenant
qu'elle est allée elle bloque bien deux
pions c'est complètement irrationnel là
je pense à me faire du live fait fit
tourner donnant à huy ah oui c'est vrai
la répétition ses joueuses ont tellement
de caractère admire à son incroyable
faut faire gaffe l'attention allez une
petite nul
encore une fois sur le mathématiques
comment t'es tu dois faire mieux sais tu
ne peux pas que je vais sur une partie
c'est comme au poker tu vas c'est une
décision qui va faire annuler un wiki
est optimale 4-2 ça y est ça fait nul
il ya une petite poisse à un creux les
opa c'est donc c'est le première fois
cette saison car match est comme ça
comme ils ont changé les règles
plusieurs fois c'est pour ça que je me
rappelle des règles de la saison
dernière qui était bien donc je pense
pas qu'ils les aient changé cet obscur
maghreb d'abord qu'est qui me guette au
japon ça rappelait les matchs qui ont
d'ailleurs c'est pour quand la deuxième
édition de notre tournoi féminin va
peut-être plus tard cette année
en fait il ya eu trop de évidemment
parce qu'il ya les événements qui on
aurait pris c'était pas si je ne me suis
pas je n'avais pas anticipé le fait que
tout le monde alors organisées tous les
mois des tours à sur internet
il ya eu un peu trop de deux championnes
ce tour en fait non il y en a vraiment
eu beaucoup il quel est ton ressenti
d'ailleurs voilà parce que je me suis
dit à un moment j'ai jeûné commenté
seulement un seul dans l'absolu et ce
qui y est on arrive toujours à garder
c'est l'engouement pour ces tournois la
hapa d'été ou non le format n'a pas du
tout changé j'ai l'impression qu'il
faillit même quand je regarde les
parties en tant que joueuse d'échecs
j'aime beaucoup je sais le jeu mais ça
ne m'intéresse pas de les regarder
enfin en fait il ya un problème fin moi
je les identifier comme ça en fait pour
moi il ya un immense problème dans les
échecs c'est que les gens dans tous les
sports ils sont dans n'importe quel
sport que tu regardes tu es intéressé
pour le cycle du championnat du monde en
quelque sorte servent que tu regardes du
fouta intéressés pour ton club
la ligue des champions au final je
regarde du tennis tout est intéressé
pour que bâton joueurs et gagner des
grands chelems et qui soit numéro un
mondial et aux échecs en fait je pense
qu'on a un très gros problème c'est que
tu as très peu de tournois qui comptent
pour quelque chose
voiture et puis en fait c'est exactement
de la vie que je donnais par rapport au
jeu en ligne ce que ça à dévaloriser le
tue c'est le jeu d'échecs
ah bah oui ça offrant un spectacle là
c'est un show en comparable aux années
précédentes mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya plus de contenu
est ce que les prix c'est contraire à
l'éthique en fait de joueurs d'échecs
est ce que les prix au fait ça quelque
part 46 comment poker mais la valeur
d'habitat mais le truc c'est que aux
échecs
enfin les échecs c'est un sport et en
fait la seule valeur que tu peux avoir
c'est les candidats c'est le cycle de
qualification aux candidats c'est les
grands prix fit c'est tous ces tournois
là et moi je pense qu'il faudrait faire
une grosse serait une grande réforme et
réussira à relier le grand chef tour les
toits du grand duché sont des beaux
événements avec le cycle de
qualification candidats en fait moi
c'est ce que je pense mais ce que j'ai
dit et je pense que c était à l'ordre du
jour et encore une fois tu vois ces
lâches et des gardes les monopoles
j'espère de l'organisation donc c'est
pas si évident pour eux probablement
d'introduire une adresse structure je
sais c'est une question d'équilibré de
pouvoir oui mais ses soutiens cesser
enfin on est obligé d'y arriver en
faites quoi qu'il arrive c'est pour moi
si ce n'est pas tant les questions de
sucettes d'introduire aussi les tournois
de grande chasse tour même si je pense
que cette une est très très bon et des
sept d'avoir peut-être le circuit
semblable au tennis à mais bien sûr mais
on a dû vous dire qu'en vrai circuit
professionnel où tous les jours c'est
encore une fois les grandes chez ce tour
ça me concerne que les joueurs d'élite
jamais mais ça serait juste mais il
faudrait réformer failli filer avec le
grand duché surface partie de ça et
réformer le grand duché ce tour aussi en
fait je parlais du grand duché sûr parce
que c'est ceux qui ont le plus d'argent
donc in fine et c'est ce qu'ils peuvent
aller faire les meilleurs tournois
bon c'est reparti brahim irak oui je
regardais je regardais la partie russe
est en même temps
c'était à peu près qu'il est vrai je
pense que jacques pas eu de gaffe
non là c'est chaud gpg page et la
personne qui m'a écrit les règles sap a
été écrit ça a été dit oralement j'ai
pas pu écouter mais on va partir sur le
fait qu'il ya quatre partis parce que ça
a été le fait qu'une hypothèse que les
jouets ce jeu quatre parties 6 etc qui
les bras après on verra
non non je crois qu'après ça joue en
mort subite choses comme il faut un truc
pas mal il n'aime pas les armageddon
généralement ils préfèrent jouer les
morts subites premier qui gagne a gagné
le match en fait et basta à avoir ce
bébé peut importer la couleur ouais moi
j'aime bien en fait se forme amende
jamais hier j'ai jamais joué encore
lorsque explique que je suis toujours en
vie probablement que lors nettement il
est sympa le format mort subite
mais là haut la gaffe ou enquête chez
les dames fcc les oublier que prend 2,4
c'était la menace on endure au lagaf est
là avec 10 secondes à la potentielle
abandonne pas ça me fait peur ce que ça
veut peut-être dire que c'est en fait il
vous mort subite à celle amorcée bien
peut-être je sais pas en fait on sait
pas ça ressemble à mort subite si elle
abandonne pas parce que je pense que si
non alors abandonné et en plus un
mickaël un carrosse à la peur d'avoir un
père pète mais je pense pas qu'il y en
bien parce qu'il est roi
cette dame à ces trois jeux 6 oui il y
avait toujours cette caste de chez 3,6
on va voir
est ce qu'il ya une autre partie ou pas
ouais ça mouille et une autre parcours
non non non ça c'est bien on a un double
suspense suspense dans les parties ont
d'un suspense sur combien de temps ça va
jouer alors dans le même plan avec des
5,7 fois à paris qui avait oublié les
pas et vous ne voulez pas je vais
essayer de position avec rouge est cette
des 4
probablement mais tout ça là c'est
qu'une main là tout est iranien je pense
vraiment et qui a valu cinq ans lors
d'un point qui est français 6 à mon avis
c'était à tu veux dire sur dingue
prendre congé quant à la fed un proche
moi qui ai vraiment qui a valu au 5 et 4
ans et 6 ans c'était je crois que
c'était dead c'était daddy directement
c'est vrai je pense que c'est dur
lakafia moi ce qui me plaît pas dans
ceux dans ce momentum là c'est qu'elle
se remet mal autant et c'est de nouveau
à rica qui à l'initiative du jeu c'est
j'ai l'impression qu'elles ont toutes
les deux leur période est classé de
nouveaux plutôt une période arica oui
c'est une baisse de régime est
clairement chez katia et comment faire
ce qu'il n'y a pas de coups faciles donc
qu'est ce que tu vas faire officiers
celle-ci peut-être officielle à tour
prendre des 4 4 obligé de faire d'amendé
cinq peut-être mais t'as pas envie de 5
e 4 elle a fait ça et tu reprends des
quatre maintenant elle est tout reprend
b4 il y avait des preuves et si ce qui
est français et 8 soudain prend b4 s'est
de nouveau fini à un peu de têtes que ça
ça lui laisse une petite chance ce camp
bullet les tours des fois ce genre de
final c'est pas toutes les pièces
mineurs sont pas si facile que ça
organisé parce que tu en a deux et
parfois c'est plus facile d'organiser
une seule pièce tac une tour à faire
jouer donc c'est plus facile de de
l'organiser lattuada mais si c'est bien
double attaque a laissé pas c'est pas
fait fait d'impro de salaire cool non
oui oui dont j'étais juste en train
d'atterrissage pour leurs déplacements
qu'à l'est les cavaliers un cas elle est
de 3 tu vois et ce que veulent et là on
va contrôler pratiquement toutes les
cases ici c'est très difficile en le
problème du fou cavaliers c'est que ces
deux pièces et que c'est beaucoup plus
dur de s'organiser la tour ces deux cas
les coûts sont plus naturels c'est notre
premier verre j'apprends beaucoup comme
ça la tour prend b2 tempe en berne
ouais
la gaffe et annoncé un autre univers
c'est là les deux pièces sont vraiment
difficiles à à quoi quoi quoi l'accord
donné tu obtiens c'est logique en vrai
en compte y pense est ce qu est ce que
le bullet et pourrait être qualifié tu
sais pas cet adjectif que les pieds
katif c'est logique
enfin bon parce qu on pourrait
l'utiliser les employés pour décrire le
bullet aller c'est localise combats ont
confiance dans le chat que c'est bien
quatre partis c'est bien comme l'année
dernière puis 2 + 2 et cette fois ci
font armageddon maintenant à la fin ils
font plus de morts subites
bon enfin cette cette voie avait laissé
de s'amplifier à chaque fois tu prends
bitumée faire ces quatre géants bien les
frères tous ces cas pour prendre la
priorité sur leflux 6 mais bon oui
faisait 4 c'était un très grand coup
surtout que les malades et noir
n'avaient pas cavalier g4 donc pas
d'intermédiaires du coup il doit faire
ce truc un peu moche la wii trois
cavaliers héros f24 dire c'est quoi trop
c'est aller on en voit dans les médias
les mains sales que je pense moi ouais
et tu vois l art réussi à tenir la
pendule ce qui est important pour katia
c'est intéressant poussé 4 elle descend
elle peut pas ouvrir la crise après les
signes clos c'est important
c'est l'école backis à ces maquis qui
m'a appris quand c'est des coudes
attaque il faut le dire en espagnol
importants dommages non pas du tout
c'est fou c'est baky en fait j'ai pas un
jour il me dit ccim qu'ogier pourquoi
ces think où est passé cinq et dix non
mais c'est un c1 ces cinq libérateur il
faut dire en espagnol il
très importants 5e rang j'ai des coups
d'attaqué en espagnol c'est génial mais
tu vois là il faut capter avec les fasse
attention c'est imperceptible mais ça
peuvent être tournées
ça commence à tourner non qu'est-ce que
moi j'aurais pris un geste et si
j'aurais joué tout rachat ne sais pas si
c'est possible c'est un peu tourner si
c'est comme quand tu fais un flan et que
tu laisses un peu trop dehors ou qu à la
quantifier la loi ça tourne alors assez
vite c'est bizarre on est tous rachats
maintenant faut toujours protéger mes
temps pensé c'est au le craquage d'arica
elle a complètement à la complètement
craqué attends attends il a pendu elle
qu'est ce que c'est à dire celle à
l'origine
qu'est ce qu'elle dit norge c'est chaud
mais après elle a eu du bol que ce soit
pas si grave hein parce qu'elle a bien
oui la princesse anglaise
elles reçoivent arrivants ces quatre là
fouet fort tourbe est un droit c'est 4 à
4 tours h 8 à 3 tours à huit en fait
elles arrivent avant l échange
je pensais qu'ils allaient mettre leur
ans et 4 avant
oui mais c'est une très très bonne
finale deux tours pour le moment 4
attend droit prend déplacement à la
raison de changer je ne sais pas elle
même elle a même le temps de reprendre
oui et re mon attention
ohlala non c'est pas c'est pas si clair
mais là encore une fois parce que
regarde elle va bouffer f3 j'ai la scène
de temps d'aller bouffer ou quatre
souhaitent une bonne nouvelle cet échec
oui mais attend est là est-ce qu'elle
répète vraiment ce qui s'est passé elle
a perdu un temps en fait
arica en faisant les échecs ella ella
elle a permis au roi de venir maintenant
ça doit être gagnant pourquoi la paf
airways 5 au nom l'hérault f5 elle
protéger les pions et c'était tout bref
si c'est le bouffer tous annoncé une
fille dormait au nom
on voit bien que c'était simple à rien
n'est simple avec quelques secondes de
la pause ils n'ont bien sûr un c c'était
simple c'est juste que si tu le vois
après c'est fini ce que tu prends ici tu
prends g5 tu prend 1,5
au nom et donc du coup c'est la dernière
oui ben avant qui est nul à temps mais
combien de fois je me suis dit pour la
coupe du monde j'ai fait je pourrais pas
l'utiliser c'est torture
je voudrais aussi moi de trouver
quelques idées mais même dans ce match
là c'est quand même pas mal d'argent jeu
en haut de la de ça je sais même pas
quels sont les prix je peux je sais pas
si j'ai si j'ai juste mais je crois que
celle qui gagne le tournoi prend 20
mille dollars quand même un coup oui
c'est juste quinze ou vingt mille ou
quelque chose comme ça donc ça peut
sortir des prépas quoi c c'est sympa oui
c'est vrai fait plaisir mais en même
temps je c'est une position encore une
fois de très équilibré je pense que je
peux jouer à trois avec les blancs mais
qu elle s est très bien joué renonce à 4
katia tu sais qu'elle est elle est quand
même par rapport à ce qu'on a eu dans
d'autres posent partie est positionné
pas si mal sorti
attention attention quand même attention
là les pions me font peur aux j'ai peur
des duos qui ont almira mais il fait
c'est bon la gamme c'est pas le meilleur
bloqueur du monde le sait c'est vêtue
mais bon pour le moment et on n'a pas
d'autres après sékou lequel elle s'est
bien faufilé jusque en d4 c'était bien
joué cette fois ci ça la joue très bien
là katia mais je pense qu'un rica et
légèrement devant à mersch 5 h 4 or
c'est dans la tête pour aller pisser g51
tant pis si 4000 à déstabiliser la
position merkel et reprend le clan tout
simplement
ouais je rejoins ne récupère pas on l'a
c'est durant la série qu'inquiétant
aulas est quasiment terminé sari 4g pas
comment tu sais rien appris à l'école
baky une déco un missclick ça c'est
l'école bas qui allait la déco qui
tombent ou le missclick faut ramener
ladarez la fusion toujours un coin parce
que sinon 23 laisser pas mal mais non
mais ça arrive de partout c'est hermine
à dos un tour f4 bien joué faux cv
saddam h5 manger tient encore au rasoir
mondial dames 3,5 à tour g4 qui arrive
elle défend encore allez faut prendre à
défaut sur toujours un coup et on rêve
de droite 3 900 points 6 tours 4 gagne
le match
ouais c'était en ligne là dessus pour
mais c'est une victoire méritée et là
vraiment mieux tenu la distance
c'est un vrai marathon ces matches là
ouais non non elle a mérité la méritait
sa victoire à rica elle a le sourire
on en était plutôt pour quartier avec
toi mais c'est quand même un bon match
il m'a dit qu'il n'y avait pas trop
d'intérêt pour ce tournoi là je pense
que ce match là il était vraiment
formidable j'espère que voilà la
communauté française l'acier mais tu
vois ce qu'est ce que ce que j'ai dit
souvent avec ses speechless et j'avais
fait le retour avec chaises comme je
leur avais proposé de base soit les
voileux première chose que j'avais
proposée c'était de commenter les demi
finales et la finale avec toi et pas
commenter le reste en fait vous avez dit
ah j'avais fait ça comme autant j'avais
dit on commentera la demi finale et la
finale avec admiral ce sera super mais
les matchs avant j'ai une grande
expérience des speechs s et je sais que
le problème c'est les 13 matches avant
en fait les demi finales et finales sont
toujours bien mais juste la compétition
est tellement longue dans le temps que
du coup les gens y viennent plus
intéressé aux moments intéressants parce
qu'ils ont été ennuyés
par le droit mais par les qualifications
en fait il faudrait trouver le moyen
peut-être quand on voit les systèmes 17
est très très intéressante mais
peut-être de valoriser chaque étape
je sais pas si on peut dire parallèle
avec d'autres sports comme le tour de
france tu vois mais que chaque étape
soin particulier parce que tu sais moi
j'avais proposé qu'en fait les huitièmes
de finale se jouent en même temps en
fait de jouer les matchs en même temps
et ne pas les mettre jour après jour et
tous les commentaires tu vois parce
qu'au final dans ces compétitions là tu
te retrouves avec des huitièmes de
finale qui dure deux semaines des quarts
de finale qui dure 10 jours et des demi
finales finale qui dure trois jours
donc tu vas même c'est bizarre en fait
on soit oui je comprends tout à fait
mais en tout cas c'était un vrai plaisir
que ça fait tellement longtemps que j'ai
pas commenté en français je posais la
question du jeu et je ne maîtrise plus
la langue de baudelaire je sais ça c'est
le russe c'est l'anglais et tu parles
très très bien non tu veux encore une
fois ce sont les automatismes comme on
parlait de bull est la langue la
maîtrise d'une langue passe aussi par en
parler
oui la belle expression est là les
lectures et quand ces derniers temps
c'était que les anglais et un
probablement j'avais aussi qu est resté
commenter la coupe du monde dames
agression fait très plaisir de monde en
tout cas on est combien de français ou
on est écoute je sais me tienne et on
est trois aussi je crois que dans le
tournoi féminin pauline marie et moi et
me train est devenue française et joue
pas à méteren est devenu français je
sais ça sur twitter en tout cas ah oui
j'ai pas du tout accès toutes ces
informations
c'est une bonne vue donc on aura le
championnat de france 6
ce sera une compétition très disputée
probablement l'année prochaine avec les
rives est démente et oui on démonte et
arrêtent dangereux va être bien préparés
à mon avis cette année machado j'ai ce
match je ne savais pas aux outils c'est
comment sortir de l'éleveur sur au moins
il faut pas il faut pas un tu perds et
puis c'est pas grave non mais ouais
c'est insupportable c'est comme quand tu
joues contre mathieu enfin c'est ça te
fait mal à la tête
c'est terrible pour du coup on se
retrouve demain c'est 13h30 un gt gt
écrit donc le dernier chênois derby
chinois et
et on verra qui dérouille ifa new thing
j
vade va défier rica en finale meares
ical sera vraiment dur à battre a
vraiment montré de grosses qualités
et vous c'est une adversaire qui est pas
facile pour crier fans justin prévisions
peut-être de cette finale là est là
déjà battus en particulier qui rappe et
de ces innocents tant que ce sera après
on a près le truc c'est qu'entre les
deux joueuses chinoises comme c'est un
derby savas les derbys favorisent
souvent les plus forts parce qu'un
impact psychologique donc je pense que
oui l'ifa n'est vraiment favorite demain
après on verra bien
bon bah c'est comme d'habitude j'ai
remercier aussi bas le chat
je sais que cette c'est un rituel qui
est très très important et je sais pas
qui viennent tu vois probablement les
questions et j'espère qu'on va pouvoir
aussi on va avoir l'occasion de discuter
mais peut-être demain le match sera
peut-être un peu plus générale
normalement il ya les matchs ya quand
même un moment donné où il ya quelqu'un
qui lâcha aujourd'hui c'était serré
jusqu'au bout mais il arrive quand même
souvent qu'on est un petit quart d'heure
en ti 20 minutes à la fin ou match et
décider ce n'était pas le cas
aujourd'hui et c'est tant mieux mais
demain ou après demain on aura forcément
un petit moment donc tout ce que je te
propose dont on va on va on va vous
laisser on va récupérer et on sera en
pleine forme demain pour commenter ce
derby chinois merci à tous et merci à
lui